Oh no,
go ahead,
click the button and we're waiting on
them.
I'd hate for you to drop some awesome
knowledge and we're alive.
That's it.
Steve Rinella.
The only hunting show ever in the
history of mediator or excuse me of
Netflix,
have meat eater.
That's a.
that's an awesome accomplishment,
man.
You're the first hunting with.
See,
I tell everybody that if you want to
watch a hunting show,
I feel like people watch hunting shows
and they go,
oh,
these shit.
What the fuck are these guys doing?
They're sitting around.
I go,
well,
look at that blue,
the size of this book,
my own.
This is amazing.
Your show is so different from all those
other shows like it belongs on something
else.
It belongs on like the history channel
or discovery channel or something more
mainstream.
So I'm glad that Netflix picked it up.
Oh Man,
I'm delighted they picked up 32
episodes.
I'm glad we got to this plugin part
right away.
Right away.
Yeah,
because if I turn people off and they
tune out,
they'll remember this man,
this is great.
I can just walk out the fucking door
right now.
Nobody episodes.
How many episodes have you guys done?
All told?
No,
no.
Have more than 75.
Way More than 75.
I think.
So there's sort of.
Just remember one day we had a little.
I remember one day I was having a drink
to celebrate us having wrapped number 50
and that was long time ago.
So we're way past that now.
Wow,
that's a good question.
It's a lot of weeks.
Upwards of 75.
It's a lot of weeks out in the field.
Yeah,
the hundredth.
Yeah.
We'll probably have a little party on
the hundredth episode,
but no,
it's been,
it's been great man.
I mean the Netflix thing is really just.
I mean it really,
you know,
exposed to a lot of,
a lot of people and it was cool.
They instead of starting with season
one,
you know,
they put up season five and six a
Netflix,
which is nice because it makes people
real curious about the other ones.
There's one episode that's probably one
of my favorite episodes you ever did
where you never shot anything.
So one episode with you alone,
deer hunting.
And he started talking about your dad.
Yeah.
Cool.
Arizona area.
No music,
a lot of ambient sound,
loud wind who makes those choices,
like those editorial choices that was,
you know,
the Ed or one of our editors,
kind of one of our core editors,
the editors that's been doing it for a
long time.
A guy by the name of guy.
He,
um,
yeah,
he,
he did that.
And at first I was like,
Huh,
what?
Because he wanted.
Yeah,
he wanted to do one,
no music.
There's no vo on it,
you know,
and we're pretty vo heavy,
sound pretty tend to be a voiceover,
like I do a lot of narrating,
you know,
um,
in fact I was just writing some
narration for the United recently,
but I do a lot of narrating and then we
just did one with,
there's no narrating.
And I think a lot of times it comes down
to how talkative I'm feeling in the
field,
you know?
Um,
and yeah,
I just,
whatever,
for whatever reason I was suffering a
little bit of exhaustion or something.
I just did a lot of rambling.
And then when he started cutting it
together,
he just wanted to run it like that with
no sound at all.
We want to one night with no music at
all.
No,
no,
no voiceover,
no.
No narration.
Just all spoken to camera.
No other people there.
So everything just like not delivered
his dialogue,
just like two camera dressing.
We talk now about doing one that has no
words in it,
but it's all music maybe
I was looking for.
I was looking for like,
excitement to register on Joe's face and
I got the opposite.
Yeah.
Well that's one of the things that I
think is most ridiculous about a lot of
hunting shows.
Just how terrible the music is.
Some of the music choices.
Just like,
what did you guys just go to fucking,
uh,
what is that program that you have on
your Mac?
When is that a garage.
Garage band?
Yeah.
Pick up some beats and I don't know the
name of the system that we use,
but it's a,
you know,
it's,
it's a searchable database of music,
like a catalog of music.
The documentary we're doing,
we're,
we're beginning now to work on,
we're in the initial stages of,
you know,
having it scored,
which is fun because it's not something
I've ever messed with,
you know,
like I,
I think we're very rarely in a
television show or do you have a
television show scored,
you know,
you're usually using library music or
licensed music.
You know,
I was watching westworld the other
night,
which is an awesome show if you haven't
seen it.
But uh,
there was one scene with his music
started playing.
I'm like,
this is so bad.
I hate this.
I hate when I'm being manipulated by
music during a scene.
Like if the music is telling you to
where you're like,
where they come up to and they're like,
man,
you're not going to feel like this isn't
making you feel how we wish it made you
feel.
Perhaps if we played this,
you'll feel this way more.
Yeah.
It's weird that we just,
this is the part where you're supposed
to feel,
you know,
kind of like a feelings of nostalgia
and,
and you know,
and like these remorseful feelings and
we have no idea how to invoke that in
audiences.
But this musician did a wonderful job
some years ago.
Let's play this.
It's always like violins and shit,
piano,
it,
there's something about that that's
just,
I feel so manipulated,
like I should just get into it,
right?
Because you're accepting these are
stories of success of like,
you're,
you're giving me a program,
you're showing me something in an hour.
You,
there's all these edits.
We're going back and why can't I just
accept that,
you know?
Uh,
there's a,
there's a musician I liked quite a bit
named Micah p Henson,
and he's,
he's out at Abilene,
Texas and he has a song called the de
Texas sank to the bottom of the sea.
And a friend of mine who's a
screenwriter,
we have joked about someday writing a
movie.
So sad that you could play that song at
the end.
It would not feel manipulative like
movies.
So sad.
It could earn to have the day text,
the sank to the bottom of the sea,
played in the end of it.
What's his name again?
Mike?
A P hints and Micah and my ca.
Yeah,
a h,
a h?
Yeah.
Seems like a young fellow.
I don't know.
He seems like he's got a background in
drug
taken a one of those guys.
Um,
but uh,
I really,
uh,
yeah,
he's a good musician,
man.
Yeah.
There's something about music in movies
that we've just totally,
we just totally accept it in television
shows and music when there's a scene and
they want to manipulate you and they
want to establish some sort of a feeling
that you're supposed to invoke.
They just lay it in there.
The radio head album.
OK.
Computer has a song called exit music
for film because I think they just felt
like it would be.
They're trying to send a message to the
licensers.
Yeah.
It's a wonder who was the first.
I guess they did that back in the movies
before there was talkies,
you know,
it was all when movies were silent.
I mean,
that's how they sort of manipulated you
and then they showed the screen and they
had the words on it that,
oh yeah,
like the Peter and the wolf thing and
then it just carried over.
But yeah.
Well we're working on the show with
music.
Um,
I've,
I've a hard time describing visual
stuff,
you know,
like I'll often see something like a
visual treatment for something,
you know,
or artwork or whatever.
I'm like,
I don't know.
I can't disappear.
I'll know it when I see it.
I'll know that I like it,
but I can't tell you what I like and
when we're doing it.
And I listened to music when the editor
is putting something together and I hear
music,
I never have suggestions.
I always just have no,
it's like,
it's me.
It's like,
it's like,
yes,
no,
no.
And I never could be like,
make it more,
you know,
I don't know,
I just had to hear it and I'd be like,
oh,
that's,
it's too heavy handed or not.
I saw one show where they were deer
hunting and there was electronic music
playing.
I was like,
who chose this?
Well,
they might be trying to create like a
weird tension.
Yeah.
Make you upset.
That way you want the deer to die
because they're forcing you to listen to
this music.
There's a great compilation of a hawks.
I think they're a rough legged hawks.
Maybe I can't remember what time,
but uh,
just bitch slap and Mallard ducks up in
Canada and the guy said it to hell's
bells now.
Always thought that
it was the obvious choice,
but just has a great effect watching a
hawks killed docs to hell's bells.
Um,
but other than that,
no,
I like it to be.
I always kinda like it to be not
obvious.
Like,
you know,
like let's say you're doing a show in
West Virginia and so on and be like,
oh yeah,
we kick it off of some Banjo music,
you know what I mean?
It's like I hate that kind of decision
making,
you know,
cliche.
Yeah.
And then,
and then I don't like it to be like
electronica to deer hunting.
Like you kind of want it to be sort of
like,
not obvious,
but.
Right.
Yeah.
Like who was it that decided to outer
space sounds the way it does,
like no one shows images of outer space
to Banjo.
Good point.
And show images of outer space like do,
do,
do you know?
Or
it's gotta be like Star Wars,
symphony type music.
Someone decided to outer space feels
like a kind of music.
So if I was doing something about outer
space,
I would want to find something that
you'd never guess was outer spacey
sounding,
but in the end you're like,
yeah,
you know what,
that's not out of place for outer space.
Like a harmonica.
Sure,
sure.
I'll know when I hear it.
I hear it.
You'd have to enlist a bunch of the
world best harmonica players who come up
with something spacey.
Yeah.
That'd be to watch outer space stuff.
I think like a didgeridoo would work for
space now.
You could do that,
but that,
but the,
all the,
all the editors
all that music up for when they got to
cut to an Australia thing.
That's true,
right?
Really?
What's Australia sound like?
Oh,
that's right.
The degree do.
Um,
but yeah man,
Netflix,
it's,
it's a,
it's got a lot of emails and people kind
of stumbling out of the show and it's
funny because you make a show about
hunting and you want to like in your
head you're like,
people that like to hunt would have
found it,
but then you,
you hear it from people who hunt their
asses off and they're like,
hey,
I just discovered the show
and it's,
and you realize this,
all these people,
like all the,
the untapped millions that are out
there.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of people like me
before I ever started hunting that are
interested in it.
They think it's interesting and I think
the gateway drug for them as those
Alaska shows those like subsistence
hunter shows like the last frontier and
the mountain men chose.
They show these people are like,
wow,
that looks cool.
Yeah.
You know,
and then I think the next step is to
switch on over the sportsmans channel or
something like that.
And something interesting point.
But you can get turned off really
easily.
You could go to the wrong kind of show
and it can be boring or you can stumble
upon,
like I always say about uncharted,
the Jim shockey show.
Have you seen that show?
I have a great show and it,
to me it's not really a hunting show.
It's a show about cultures and travel
and culture.
Yeah.
It's about a really curious,
open minded guy who loves to go to
different cultures and he goes there,
you know,
and the premises.
He goes there to hunt,
but he's,
he's traveled to some really,
really incredible places and film some
amazing stuff.
Did you see the one where he went to?
Um,
I forget what river it was in Africa
where these people have a significant
problem with crocodiles eating.
Oh no I didn't,
but I've talked to some people about
that one.
Everybody in the village was like
missing an arm.
They had a hole in their head.
This.
Everybody had been jacked and while he
was there,
a woman got taken.
No,
it was crazy watching these people wail
and cry and sob.
It was really,
really intense.
You know what?
I was in a
seventh grade.
We had a teacher named Ms Dot Merkel.
I don't know if she's alive anymore,
but I remember she lived down the
Muskegon river.
She was in the Peace Corps and one,
look at this.
What we'll see is the hands on your kid
and you realize later.
It's weird.
One day she brought in a photograph
of her,
I believe it was her fiance at the time
of his body after it had been removed
from a crocodile's stomach.
Holy Shit.
To show us
now to set that,
to set the times.
I also,
when I was in ninth grade,
there was a teacher named Mr Wright and
he wanted me to read blue,
a shotgun form.
You know the bluing on the shotgun,
like the coding on a shotgun and blew
it.
Yeah.
How do you do that?
What is it?
It's a chemical dip.
You Strip it and then it's like a
chemical treatment blooming blooming.
It's kind of fallen out of favor,
but everything used to be blue.
Anyways,
just set scene like for what you could
do back then that you don't do now.
He gave a shotgun to a kid,
brought shotgun school,
gave me the shotgun.
I took her home,
reboot it.
You know what?
He paid me back with what?
He gave me a 25 caliber semiautomatic
handgun in a sweat sock
school.
I brought it home and my dad confiscated
it from me and I never saw it again.
Wow.
So the teacher gave you a hand gun.
What the fuck is this teacher doing?
Give me that.
Yeah.
Wow.
Twenty five caliber.
Semi auto in a sweat soc as payment for
blue and his shotgun.
The transaction all happened at
[inaudible].
Is that in Michigan?
It's my high school.
So when I say the shadow,
she had a photo of a guy's body coming
out of a crocodile.
It's like just the,
you know,
that's not that long ago though.
No,
I'm 43 now.
How old am I?
40 two times have changed pretty
radically.
Oh yeah.
I remember when they instituted the rule
that you couldn't have firearms at
school and I remember going down and
talking to Mr Backman and being like,
hey,
you know,
and he's like,
oh yeah,
of course.
I mean,
you know,
you guys aren't
and everything
so you can stick a gun in your locker.
Have it
your car in the parking lot though.
Wow.
Now for our documentary,
we interviewed a guy who used to get on
his school bus with his shotgun,
Holy Shit in Martha's vineyard of all
places and he would get on the school
bus with the shotgun.
Wow.
So yeah.
So he could hunt ducks afterschool.
Whoa.
How old is this guy?
Old.
He's a Vietnam veteran.
Wow.
What happened?
Started shooting people at school.
I don't know if we could answer that.
I've been talking about this a lot.
What happened to go and postal?
What did the post office figure out how
the post office get it together?
Like why did that stop happening?
Like was it.
It was a huge issue.
There was a game called postal.
There was a video game that you could
play in the early days of video game
called postal and this is another thing
that you probably couldn't do today,
but there was a video game based on mass
shootings.
We'd go to a post office just fuck
everybody up,
but was,
I don't remember.
I,
I know.
Of course I remembered that,
but I don't remember word.
They're actually like more than two.
Yeah,
I was going to say it's called running
with scissors.
Was the company that made it look like
this is the fucking game you would just
run around and shoot people and chop
them up and got them down.
I mean,
it's terrible graphics because it's the
early days of gun or excuse me with
video games?
No,
it looks like my six year old did the
pictures,
but this is the game and this is like
the original grand theft daughter auto.
Really?
Yeah.
How can we could just go over the roof
like that shitty ass physics.
Yeah.
I mean going postal was a thing that
people used to say all the time,
but if you said,
uh,
he went postal to like a tire now you
know,
people talk about.
I think people will use.
Use it as being.
You got real mad.
I think it's a murderous thing.
No,
I know.
But once it became in the lexicon,
you know,
you could say like,
Oh yeah,
you know,
he went and posted all about me,
not,
you know.
Right.
Sending them the check.
But you could say going postal because
you're 42,
but could you say postal if you're 22,
I don't think a 22 year old.
Any idea what you're talking about?
Something happened.
It ended the,
the,
the phenomena.
Yeah.
What did the post office do?
Questioning is.
What was it based on?
Two things.
Three.
Monotony.
Inbox.
Outbox inbox outbox.
No.
Yeah,
but I mean,
I mean,
how many postal,
how many,
how many exam were there at post
offices?
Jamie's pulled them up here.
Look at this to a 19,
86,
1991.
Ninety one again,
two events in [inaudible] 93 and took a
13 year height and then it came back
strong in 2006.
Baker city,
Oregon,
2006.
So 2006.
It seems like that was the last postal
event.
Says that was based around these ones in
1986 is where the term started.
So it probably is just a novelty thing,
like one person did it and then a bunch
of other people.
Well,
I wonder if there's a disproportionate
amount of mass shootings and post
offices as compared to other warehouse
jobs or other.
I mean,
because there's been mass shootings at
work before,
but for some reason that distinction got
put on post office
said 35 people and 11 incidents that is
high.
It's fairly high,
but when you're,
you know,
you're dealing with the number of people
that come in and out of the post office.
Irate.
Yeah.
But it's one of those weird things.
It's like,
why don't you see that about Jiffy Lube?
There's no Jiffy Lube,
mass shootings,
you know?
Yeah.
I can't answer that.
I bet there's people who studied at
carefully.
I read the book,
I read the Book Columbine.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You read that book?
No,
I didn't,
but I just got a book from one of the
kids that survived,
uh,
met him.
He was with Marilyn Manson at this
podcast that we did for the election
night,
the end of the world podcast.
And uh,
he gave me a copy of his book.
He survived,
they came up to him right before the
shooting and they said,
hey man,
we like,
you get the fuck outta here.
Really?
Yeah.
And he left and guns started blazing.
He survived.
Yeah,
that'd be a good guy to have on your
show.
I'm going to have them on the guy to go
to calm him by me.
The guy that wrote Columbine.
Columbine is a good book man.
I mean as far as the psychology of,
of,
you know,
the psychology and background and
context of shooters.
It's,
it's a good book.
It's an intense phenomenon,
you know,
that is attributed to North America more
than anywhere.
I mean you starting to see a lot more
mass shootings all across the world,
but a lot of them are religious related,
but it's,
it's,
it's a very,
it's a very confusing one to people
because there's so many factors
involved,
you know,
and it's one that gets lumped in with a
gun culture.
Like,
this is a tweet that I put on my twitter
page while back that I said this country
has a mental health problem disguised as
a gun problem.
You know,
and I really,
really believe that.
I just,
I don't think you can attribute,
there's so many guns in this country and
so few mass shootings.
There's so many guns.
I mean the number of guns exceeds the
number of people and the amount of mass
shootings in relative.
Obviously they're all horrible,
horrific and terrible,
but relatively to the,
to the amount of people that we have,
it's relatively small.
I think that the kind of person that can
engage in something like that,
there's so many factors and you can't
blame it on guns.
It's like blaming forks on people,
getting fat.
It doesn't make sense.
You know,
like when you look at the tendency to
want to like grasp bond to somewhat easy
solutions for stuff,
it's something people go to.
Yes.
Because it's like,
it seems conquerable you know,
so people go,
people look at like a really complex
thing.
We saw so much this during the round of
the presidential election where,
you know,
to make a point really fast,
you look at something that's
terrifically complex and it's not just
that you want the magic solution,
but who would kind of go like,
well,
what could be pop,
what possibly could be done?
And I think people move in the direction
of moving in the direction of the second
amendment.
And there's also this sort of an
agreement that people have when
discussing it.
Like yes,
guns are a problem and that guns are a
problem because these things happen.
And then they all start talking about
guns and then if we get lumped into two
groups,
you get lumped into people that are pro
second amendment that go,
no,
it's not guns.
And then the people that say,
wow,
those crazy people with guns,
you know,
Obama.
That was one of the famous,
one of the famous statement that he said
during his administration is how people
are so attached to their guns and,
and the,
the second amendment people got so mad.
The NRA.
People like the cling into religion and
guns.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
if you just look at the sheer number of
people who actually have guns in this
country,
it is a little crazy.
I mean the volume is very,
very high.
The actual number of firearms and the
thing that always gets me is they don't,
it's not like they stopped making them.
I mean they're making guns every day,
you know,
a lot less now since the election.
Really.
Yeah.
I had this trump white friends,
right.
Are
So convinced that um,
you know,
or like,
like most people in the country or
whether you liked it or not,
we're convinced that Clinton was gonna
win,
you know,
and they,
they had,
I got it.
I got one friend in particular that went
out and bought a bunch of stocks for
company,
you know,
fire her companies and he said they took
a little hit after the election because
people are relaxed.
They didn't worry about stockpiling.
People aren't worried about stock pond.
I mean we were all talking about it is
like the,
the,
the stockpiling thing is self
perpetuating.
Where when I,
when I was a little kid,
you know,
in our Christmas stocking we would get
bricks at 22 shells because we use 22,
we'd hunt small,
we'd done a lot of squirrels and
rabbits,
20 twos and it's just like you always at
22 shells,
you know,
you could go anywhere and get 22 shells,
a body mind one of our camera guys,
he grew up on a ranch and at the ranch
store they had two items chew,
so tins of chew in 22 shells that you
could get on credit at the ranch store.
The ranch store was a,
had a very limited inventory,
but that's like how pervasive 22 shells
were.
Now when Obama won,
you know,
no one's going to use it.
Twenty two,
22 is not a goto caliber for,
for doing,
inflicting harm on other human beings.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's just not a great.
It's a very small,
small game round.
But the history about guns drove people
to gobble up 22 animal.
So all of a sudden then it was you
couldn't find 20 to animal and not being
able to find it.
Like I used to just buy these little
boxes of 50,
right?
It,
you go like,
oh,
it's hard to buy it and then all of a
sudden you've gotten the need where you
wanted to buy all you could get because
it was in your head that you couldn't
get it.
So then you'd see a thousand of them and
I'd be like,
I'm going to buy it because everyone's
buying it.
And I think it was self perpetuating.
Now I got shitloads of 22 shifts.
But I was like,
I had no need for them.
I just,
I,
I felt in this thing like there's this
thing that I've always had access to and
I won't have access to it,
you know?
And,
and it,
I don't know where it came from.
And I think that now all through the
last eight years,
there's been just this,
there's been this like great arming of
America because I feel like so many
people were worried about having their
rights and fringed it was like,
there's like,
at least now in that community of which
I'm apart,
I suppose there's a,
there's a,
there's a sigh of relief.
You.
Yeah,
there's a great relaxation amongst
sports when they think that trump is
gonna come in and,
you know,
protect the second amendment rights.
But a lot of people got to do,
have to be worried about private land or
public land.
Yeah.
That's the thing that I'm really
watching.
Um,
and I'm curious about it,
you know,
at this point,
the talks over,
right,
the rhetorics over.
So now I'm a
for,
you know,
whether someone was forward or against
it for or against trump's victory.
I think now like the responsible thing
to do in my mind are the realistic,
responsible thing to do.
My mind is because there's so many
unknowns,
just approached the administration with
an open mind.
I mean,
you know,
be like,
now I'm like,
okay,
the talks over now like what's gonna,
what's gonna happen,
like what sorts of things that we're
going to see come out of it and I don't
know if anyone really knows the answer
to that and,
and like in my outward public facing
way,
I don't generally talk about politics
outside of issues that relate to
wildlife issues that relate to hunters
and fishermen.
Right.
Like I kind of focused in because I
politically,
I'm a mess,
you know,
I'm all over the place.
Um,
I have no use for and I know you don't
either.
I have no use for like classic
definitions of conservatives,
liberals to just,
that shit makes no sense to me.
Like I don't get,
I don't draw my viewpoints from going
and looking and finding out how I'm
supposed to feel about it in order to be
like a consistent part isn't individual.
Um,
last January though,
uh,
for people who aren't even theirs,
I'm sure it's probably a lot of people
aren't familiar with this.
Can I get,
can I give a quick rundown on public
lands?
Yeah.
So the federal government has holds,
owns millions and millions of acres of
land in the US,
primarily in the western us.
And there's a handful of different land
holding agencies.
You have the bureau of land management,
manages lands,
the US fish and wildlife service manages
lands through the refuge system.
So when those boys,
uh,
in Oregon took over the wildlife refuge
there,
that was a,
that was actually,
um,
us fish and wildlife service land wasn't
blm land.
You've got the national forest holds
Land National Forest Service,
which is under the Usta already said the
Blm,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
and then of course you have,
you know,
a states owned public land,
but the but the federal land management
agencies of which there are several hold
deed to millions acres land and,
and they wrap it is owned by the
American people and it's represented
through,
you might think of it as represented
through a trust and the trust is
administered by the federal government
on your behalf.
That's our public lands where people
recreate,
um,
oh,
another large holder of public lands and
National Parks Service.
I didn't mention that one.
A gene in the lower 48,
you don't,
you don't hunt on national park land,
you fish on national park land and you
generally haunt national land bureau,
land management,
land refuge land,
and uh,
there's a push right now to the people
feel that we should,
that the federal government should be
dumping a lot of federal land.
Um,
now the,
for what reason,
why you asked that,
that's what I'm good at.
So people get frustrated with dealing
with the federal bureaucracy.
And the reason that is,
is generally the feds are pretty.
I mean this is a gross generalization,
but generally the feds are pretty,
are much slower on exploitation of
natural resources,
less responsive to demand for
exploitation,
natural resources than state agencies
are.
So federal lands,
you know,
they're there.
They in exercising the will of the
American people,
federal land agencies are,
I'm
not as easy to deal with when it comes
to mining and development and other
issues as state agencies are.
So people who are,
who want to see a more readily
exploitable system in place for,
for developers,
miners,
loggers,
others will want to see like people able
to more readily make a buck off the
land,
they'd like to see these lands that are
federal lands,
they'd like to see him go into private
hands or like to see him go into state
hands because they know that either way
it goes,
if they go into private hands or state
lands,
they're gonna have a much easier time
doing extractive industries in
development on those lands.
So that's what that's like under the
surface.
What's going on?
Um,
and then for instance,
like the guy,
you know,
one of the reasons the guys that took
over the refuge,
the,
a wildlife refuge in Oregon,
one of their gripes was they run cattle
on public property,
right?
So they pay a fee that one of those
families is heavily involved in running
cattle on federal land and they pay a
fee far below the going rate to run
cattle on public lands.
So this is what you'd go pay a branch,
or if you wanted to run cattle on his
land,
they pay about 10 percent of that by
some estimations to run it on public
land.
And then when federal land managers
don't want to renew those contracts
because again,
because people are thinking about other
issues,
other uses for the land or whatever they
want to do with it,
it causes an intense amount of,
like a serious amount of frustration
with people.
So there's people don't want to dump
lands.
Now,
I heard Donald Trump speak,
uh,
last January,
so almost a year ago in Las Vegas,
and he was standing 40 yards away from
me and was talking about the that he has
no desire to see the,
he has no desire to see our public lands
privatized.
However,
um,
he's,
you know,
one might argue kind of by name only.
He's,
he's Republican.
I mean,
he's not.
He definitely hasn't demonstrated in any
sense of being beholden to party
orthodoxy.
I mean,
he's like,
he takes it issue by issue,
stance on things and doesn't really care
for how things are done at the party
level.
However,
his party is very much a,
you know,
they've,
it's,
it's right in there.
It's one of the planks of their platform
is right in their agenda to see us dump
federal property to see us offload
federal lands,
to see us offload American public lands
to,
into,
into state or private holdings.
So I don't know,
I,
I hope that he has good.
I hope he has luck and resisting that if
in fact,
if in fact he is still standing by that
statement that you made.
I don't think most people in America
understand how unique this situation is,
that we have these massive swaths of
public land.
No,
they don't,
they,
it's one of those things where,
and even the people that do,
even the people that know don't really
conceptualize,
like I grew up,
um,
I grew up about two and a half miles
south of the southern terminus of
manistee national forest in Michigan.
Uh,
a significant portion of our outdoor
activities took place on that national
forest.
We took it like,
it fell from,
like,
our perception of it was that it fell
from the sky.
It was that it just existed.
Um,
just had always existed,
we took it for granted,
like how you look at the sun and be
like,
the sun is just there,
you know.
So I think that even people who are
public lands users don't often don't
take the time to be like,
how is it that I'm able to be on this
land,
why I never considered it at all until I
hung out with,
you know,
but I,
but I'm saying I hung out on public
lands and it wasn't for,
it wasn't until I was,
you know,
it took me 25 years to start being like
not home.
It now what does this now,
this public lands you speak of that you
hold deed like the,
as an American citizen at,
in most ways as a global citizen because
our national for our public lands are
open to anyone American or not right?
But as an American citizen,
you hold deed to hundreds of millions of
acres of land.
Now there are conditions to your use
like just things you can and cannot do,
but you're free to roam camp,
Hunt Fish,
look at the stars,
whatever.
You're extraordinarily wealthy.
Um,
and these things that came about,
like they came out in various ways,
it's probably the most influential
person in creating the public land
system we have now is Theodore
Roosevelt,
and he was controversial in his time for
creating,
are for helping to create our public
land system.
He had the same resistance when he was
doing it from industry,
from extractive industry.
He had the same resistance that we have
now to public lands and then went and
chiseled his face on a mountain because
everyone,
like now everyone,
every politician would like to liken
himself to Roosevelt.
Right,
right.
He's like one of those dudes and you can
just be like,
like Teddy Roosevelt.
And people are like,
yeah,
positive feelings,
positive feelings.
He's achieved rushmore.
This was a guy who was like a radical.
You see a little bit of that with
Reagan.
Yeah.
During the Reagan administration during
the time where he was actually president
and massively polarizing figure.
Yeah.
People hated him.
I mean,
there was,
there was so much going on during the
Iran Contra hearings where it's like,
oh my God,
who is this asshole that we let run
president?
Yeah,
I think around the time,
like by the time he died he had to sort
of ascended to political heaven.
Yeah.
Right.
Now you can,
like,
Kennedy enjoys that position.
I mean,
Kennedy barely won the damn election.
Yeah.
It's,
it's debated whether he actually won
the,
you know,
people say it all these volts wound up
in Lake Michigan.
Well there's a lot of fucking
shenanigans going on with that election
with the Mafia.
And that was a big part of how he got
elected.
So,
but later in life,
reluctant look back and say,
now there is a guy.
Right.
And so roosevelt creating our national
forest system.
Um,
yeah,
he was considered a radical.
Yeah.
It was like this outlandish idea,
like,
you mean to tell me you're just going to
take huge chunks of land.
They could earn some individuals an
extraordinary amount of money right now
and just set it aside for just joe blow
future person to enjoy.
And he even made a point where he went
on to say at one time that,
that he was doing it for those in the
womb of time.
Whoa.
Because at the time people were arguing
like,
okay,
if public land like,
because here's the other thing we
haven't that kind of pertains to this is
wildlife in the Americas publicly owned.
It's not like most countries is not like
that.
Like while leaving us is publicly owned,
so a deer.
If you've got a deer standing on your
neighbor's place,
you as not a federal citizen citizen,
but you as a citizen of your state owned
that deer.
That person can control access to it,
but it's not as deer.
He can prevent you from going up to it
because you can't go on his land,
but he has no more right to that deer
than you do generally speaking.
So when people said to Roosevelt like,
how are you blocking industry out of all
these lands and how are you blocking
industry from getting at the the
wildlife so we can sell the wildlife?
Back when we had commercial hunting,
he goes,
if you're,
if it's for the people,
give it to us,
and that's when he had his line.
He's like,
yeah,
but it's for the,
for those still in the womb of time.
That's deep.
People didn't like them.
I'm sure someone tried to do that today.
Dude.
He had a thing one time where he had a
timeline.
He had to.
He had to drop.
There was a.
There was an endo when he could.
He kept just throwing shit into national
forest for everyday.
That guy was an office.
I think he saved about something like
50,000 square miles of land or
something,
some sort of model and for everyday I
could be wrong with that,
but an absurd amount of land for
everyday.
He was an office and there's a thing he
did call the midnight forest where he
had a deadline that expired,
like his ability to keep drawing up.
Big Chunks of national forest was set to
expire at a certain time on midnight and
he was up
to last minute and midnight with a
couple aides marking up maps making
giant national forest and now we
celebrate them all.
Wow.
Right.
When they made.
When they made yellowstone also national
park,
people were pissed.
I'm sure mineral resources in their
mental piss today.
Timber in there.
Yeah,
but I'm saying all these big decisions
like these decisions happen,
did we create a public land system in
America?
Like the decision happens generally
people look and go,
wow,
what foresight,
you know,
it's kind of this insane idea that you
would have a country is prosperous as
ours,
you know,
with our GMP,
$350 million citizens,
right?
You'd have this.
Like this thing is huge as us that would
still have and intact suite of
megafauna.
No one else pulls that off.
So we've accomplished a lot.
But then now and then people just get
pissed because they want to be able to
do stuff while they want.
There's like interests that want to make
money and when they want to make money
and if someone tells him no,
um,
they get a little bit pissy and then the
smart ones of them and I will know and I
would never detract from their
intelligence.
The smart ones have them.
Um,
rather than walking away,
they go like,
well,
how is this law?
Why is the law this way and what can we
do about it?
And Right now,
those folks,
those folks have an idea that,
that the solution to their problem is
that we would
begin undoing the great work of people
like Roosevelt and Gifford Pincho and
Aldo Leopold and all these,
a seminal American figures that we
would,
we would undo their work and go back to
a system where,
um,
where these landscapes are privatized
people who've never been to yellowstone.
And I mean,
even if you're not a hunter,
you,
you should go once a yellowstone anyway.
Right?
That's the point.
Yeah,
I have problem with that Dan Jordan,
but it's,
I,
it's just forget about hunting,
just the fact that we have this immense
state park that you could go to.
And I took my kids there this summer and
uh,
we hung out with Buffalo,
were like standing there that there was
a buffalo that was 100 yards away,
which is looking at these giant,
huge prehistoric animals.
Yeah,
it's a great place for introductory
wildlife viewing.
We have,
we took a lot of selfies with elk
because the elk,
because the wolf population has
increased in yellowstone,
the elk have decided,
look,
there's one spot to hang out the fucking
visitor center.
Yeah.
So you got by the visitor center.
There's a coca cola machine,
is a vending machine and a right next to
the vending machine.
There's a fucking elk just chilling,
just laying down there.
I mean they have zero fear of people and
it's amazing how they become sort of
acclimated,
habituated,
betray his work.
It's funny when you look at,
there's a problem.
I've identified it as much as I love
yellowstone.
It in my perspective that as a fellow
that does what I do for food and,
and,
and enjoyment,
which is to hunt A.
I look at it from a grand wildlife thing
and I look at it as a,
it serves the purpose of being just like
fantastic wildlife sanctuary,
you know,
and everyone,
like,
you know,
our,
our mutual friend Doug,
during,
um,
even on his farm,
right?
He has established a,
like a sanctuary area,
like on his farm,
a place where you don't go that it's
always a spot where we're deer go and
they don't get harassed in that area and
it's like a self imposed sanctuary and
so you have yellowstone provides that,
but if identified this sorta thing,
um,
the idea I've been working on called
Yellowstone Syndrome though is where
people,
Americans,
some,
so many of them,
they're only id about wildlife and
wildlife politics and wildlife
management comes from the yellowstone
story,
that they wind up having a difficult
time understanding wildlife and wildlife
management in situations that are
outside of a national park setting,
which is to say they don't have a very
good grasp on the inevitable conflicts
that are going to arise between wildlife
and society.
And that's a large chunk of ground where
you just do not have those sorts of
conflicts.
Like what kind of conflicts we talking
about.
Oh,
like for instance,
a thing has been very difficult and very
vexing for wildlife managers is what
happens to a what,
what happens to buffalo when they leave
national?
The yellowstone national park.
I'm just,
I mean,
tobacco on the,
on the yellowstone is she goes to get a
sense for how revolutionary that idea
was,
you know,
there was the Indian wars weren't even
over when they made yellowstone.
Yellowstone,
you know,
we were,
we were still battling American Indians
on the Great Plains when you also want
it to affect,
matter of fact,
yellowstone was a park when the Nez
perce were chased through by the US army
and they actually killed a couple of
terrorists in yellowstone bright at some
of the buildings that are still there.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you,
you went to and got shot by Indians who
were engaged in a war with the US army.
Wow.
It was like a,
it was,
it was like they hadn't even,
you know,
the West hadn't even been in some ways
that the center west hadn't even been
settled and they were made and they made
the national park and then Roosevelt
went there and uh,
you know,
at the commemoration to like,
it was,
you know,
went there to applaud it.
So I just get a sense of like,
I mean just it was just an outlandish
idea,
was so far ahead of its time,
but with like the buffalo inch situation
for instance,
how it's kind of,
how it sort of is like colored.
The broader conversation would be a.
You also is one of the few places where
they've,
where the animal buffalo or bison,
you know,
they're,
they're lenay and name is bison.
Bison.
Some people say it's bison.
Bison as opposed to bison.
Bison Atha backus at the baskets,
but a buffalo,
I call them Buffalo,
ca.
It's very controversial to calm.
You're not cool if you call them
buffalo,
really know you're suppose to call them
bison who you're hanging out with.
Old timey folk.
They use coyote.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Well Kyle.
So let's get to that in.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll call them both Dan Flores books.
Oh you are good with that.
Good.
I'm going to call them bison.
What the hell?
So it's [inaudible] was one of the few
places where bison have always existed.
Now at a time,
the ones there were fenced and fed,
but they've always been there.
And your then you have there is you have
a genetically pure strain or there's
been no cattle intro aggression into
those animals.
There's only a handful of herds in the
US that were,
there hasn't been some amount of cattle
integration.
Um,
you can't see it usually,
but it's there.
Oftentimes there's some New Mexico that
don't.
There's some of the Dakotas that do not
in the yellowstone ones do not,
they've never interbred or bending and
interbred with cattle.
So they're valuable in that way.
And you know,
at various times there's,
you know,
a few thousand of them in the park and
the snow's pile up and one of the things
they like to do when the snow piles up,
so you'd like to leave the park and
they'd go out at West Yellowstone,
which is one of the primary entrance
points into the,
into the park.
And they'll go out and,
and the late at the gardener entrance in
the late winter that were pro,
that would be fine.
Probably maybe be kind of fun if it
weren't for a couple of issues.
Uh,
there's a,
there's a livestock disease called
brucellosis and it's a year age and
disease.
So it was a,
it's a,
it's a nine,
eight,
you know,
we don't know everything of diseases as
being native or non native,
but it's a non native disease called
Brucellosis and brucellosis causes
cattle to it causes heifers,
heifers,
the kyle.
That's hasn't,
you know,
with just one young.
So halfers a cow that said having her
first going to have her first calf,
it causes the heifers to abort their
fetus.
Now they've gotten brucellosis
eradicated from cattle hurts.
Generally when a state is getting
brucellosis cases they have to pay for
testing.
Okay.
So it's expensive to get all your cows
tests,
but if you have brucellosis in your
state,
the producers got to pay the testing to
get them tested to make sure that not
brucellosis positive.
Well cattle long ago past brucellosis to
the Bison on the Bison leave the park.
They carry brucellosis with them and
could reintroduce it into cattle herds
though that hasn't.
There's no known case of that happening.
I don't have it spread.
They well,
uh,
the primary way it spread his animals
eat their own afterbirth and Lee after
birth of other animals.
That's an interesting thing.
Why the ether?
You know,
some folks he thrown.
I proposed that to my wife.
She was not down with it at all,
but I've got friends that take their
placenta.
I got some buddies that had their wives
placentas made into pills.
Pills?
Yeah.
There's some gal that dries it up and
puts it in capsules for you.
I've heard of people cooking it with
carrots.
Yeah.
I wanted to cook some man,
but their thing is when my wife,
uh,
I swore up and down like I was going to
drink the breast milk,
you know,
I've got a body to put breast milk in
his coffee and everything.
Man,
you know,
and do to nea and I couldn't go near.
Does he wear a diaper to know?
But he's like,
he'll go if he's going to have coffee,
you know,
w when women are breastfeeding,
they have little bottles in the fridge
and everything.
Yeah.
He just go in there,
grab one of those,
put it in his coffee and cheese.
It's just drink it.
I tried it just to taste,
but I felt like I was stealing from my
kid.
I felt like I was being a cannibal,
which is one thing that's my.
That's where I draw a line.
That's where you draw the line.
Well,
you ate a monkey.
Yeah,
I know and I felt horrible.
Did you know?
Yeah,
I felt real bad.
Well not so bad.
I didn't eat it,
but it was,
it was.
It was like emotionally complicated for
me.
But.
So we'll get back to that.
Yeah.
The brucellosis deal.
I'm trying to get.
I'm trying to excel in yellow.
I'm trying to explain like yellowstone
syndrome.
So the bruise,
the lowest.
The steel is a real issue for some
people.
So it conceivably a buffalo could leave
yellowstone,
give birth.
The afterbirth could be their cow,
could eat that after birth can get blue
brucellosis and like everything.
And like everything we're talking about,
this is so there's so many caveats and
complications and things such as elk
have brucellosis but outcome and go as
they please.
Right?
So the minute a buffalo or bison,
when he leaves Yellowstone National
Park,
if he walks into Montana now,
it's not even fenced,
right?
It's like he doesn't know,
but when he crosses the line,
he goes from being a wild animal,
from being native wildlife.
Okay.
To being livestock.
So he goes from being the property of
like under the administration of the
National Park Service to the
administration of Montana's Department
of livestock.
Wow.
Native animal.
Now she goes,
how does that work though,
if the native animal crosses over onto
private property is the only.
He's the only animal that happens too.
So coyotes,
Fox,
Wolverines,
grizzly bears,
black bears,
bighorn sheep,
elk,
mule deer,
white tail deer,
Moose.
They leave their wildlife.
Buffalo leaves.
He becomes errant livestock.
Wow.
Therefore,
every year there's a,
you know,
there's a perennial story every year
where a bunch of buffalo leave the park
and get rounded up by the Department of
livestock and sent to quarantine are
usually sent off to slaughter.
Yeah,
they just killed a bunch of them.
They killed like 2000 of them.
Yeah man,
they get,
they get a lot of them.
Um,
you know,
that plays cranks out a lot of animals
too.
So it's like they're always throwing out
these humongous numbers of animals
they've gotten in and every year you
wind up having quite a few animals in
the park.
So,
uh,
but it's a thing now people point out
this because elk have brucellosis in elk
are calving in proximity to cattle and
there and as far as we know that there's
not like all your in class cases of
cattle,
of elk transmitting brucellosis to
cattle.
People wonder like,
well why are bison picked on?
You know,
why them.
And one thing might be to say that we
got,
and this is generally true of wildlife
in America,
I think there was a brief period around
1900 when we had,
you know,
maybe about 75 of them left in the US.
People got very used to their sort of
like not being Buffalo Bison.
And now this becoming like an a player
again is the,
the animals becoming a player again that
we now have.
We were down to 75.
We've got 500,000 in the US now.
Ninety four percent of them are
privately owned,
but we have a population of a half
million buffalo in his country.
Um,
so.
But we got really used to them not being
around.
And so it was this thing,
it was like this additive thing.
Like I think if there had been a long
period when there were no elk.
And then all of a sudden someone said,
hey,
guess what?
We're bringing these big ass ungulates
back the eat tons of stuff.
And they're huge and they might have a
disease and we're just going to let tens
of thousands of them cut loose across
the landscape,
have been up in arms,
but they were used to it because elk are
always on the ground.
So that's why buffalo recovery has been
so hard because it's kind,
kinda like you're trying to sell people
on this new thing,
even though historically it's hardly new
they've been around,
but there's just,
there was a period of,
you know,
century,
not quite a century when it wasn't an
issue.
So it's really hard to get livestock
interest and private land owners around
these areas to unanimously get on board
with the idea that we're gonna have
animals roaming out of the park that
are,
has been proven to happen that will get
into your corral and kill your horse or,
you know,
take out a school bus if it hits them or
possibly transmit disease.
And the big thing that people don't
really talk about but which is a huge
issue is um,
impact grazing rights,
impact cattle,
cattle grazing,
get back to kill the horse.
You had a gore that Gore stuff,
they just go into the horse of stable
and fuck them out.
It's happened when they run,
they run crazy.
Yeah.
They wrote in the summer and in the
Bulls get very.
They get real fired up and then,
you know,
the funny thing there too with,
with the yellowstone ones,
you're dealing with animals that are
habituated,
so it's only been like,
you know,
it's been 100 years that you can't.
You haven't been able to hunt in the
park.
The animals have gotten habituated to
humans.
We like to look at yellowstone,
think you're seeing something kind of
natural,
but you're actually seeing something
pretty unnatural because that landscape
was hunted for 12,000 years the last
hundred years,
not withstanding.
So the he wrote always hunted
yellowstone.
The unnatural thing is these animals are
super comfortable.
Being habituated to humans is unusual,
but we go there and be like,
this is what animals were like.
I'm like,
not if you draw a line back to when
humans arrived in the new world.
Well,
that was one of the more fascinating
things about Dan Flores on your podcast
where he was talking about buffalo and
that at one point in time the Indians or
the native Americans when they had guns
and they had horses,
they were on their way to extra painting
the buffalo on their own.
Yeah.
Before the market hunters came into
place.
That's an incredibly controversial idea.
That was a.
yeah,
that was a controversial idea.
Now is put for again,
not I talk in my book that I wrote,
you know,
I have a book of American Buffalo about,
the history of the animal and,
and in my own personal experiences is
hunting for the animal and finding a
skull of one that I found that absorb a
journey that led me down.
But in working on that book,
I spent a quiet time reading the work of
Dan Flores and he was a mentor of mine
in graduate school and he,
and he wrote this a very interesting
piece called Bison Ecology Bison
diplomacy.
And what he looked at was he was trying
to find,
was there a period when,
um,
when plains tribes.
Okay,
was there a period when native Americans
had actually reached equilibrium with
the bison herds and,
and he argued that there was,
not,
that they had not achieved equilibrium,
um,
that even if that one of the,
one of the points he makes many points
this thing out,
I don't want to sell.
This is pete short,
it's a,
it's a very large piece of scholarly
work,
but one of the things he talks about is
just the introduction of the horse
had humongous impacts on the animals on
buffalo for a handful of reasons.
Grazing competition.
Okay.
So enormous hort herds of wild horses
and the horse was distributed.
So you traced in flurries explains all
of this as well.
You can trace horses in to native
American tribes on the Great Plains and
elsewhere they go back to the Pueblo
revolt.
So you know,
the Spanish can keep the doors last lot
of their animals and the animals are
traded up the east earned face and up
the western face to the rockies.
And then we're distributed all around.
And so you're,
when you get this idea in your head of
a,
of a,
of a plains warrior right,
mounted on horseback hunting for
Buffalo,
that was a very distinct phenomenon that
didn't last
nearly.
It didn't last as long as the US has
been a country
like it did not last long between the
introduction of the horse and the Indian
wars
they want to.
But like largely,
you know,
re removing free roaming,
um,
autonomous tribes off off the great
plains.
It just didn't last that long even
though it became like the iconic image
of the mountain plains hunter.
And what he argues is the advent of the
horse changed hunting practices.
So much up until that point,
you had tribes that were,
were partially or largely agrarian
coming out of the Mississippi River
valley out of the Missouri River valley
that would grow crops.
And they would,
during the summer when the buffalo herds
were gathered into tremendous gatherings
during the breeding season,
they would do trips.
They would do buffalo hunting trips.
Once they had the horse.
You had all these cultures turn into
nomadic cultures that could have a troy
and a horse and just follow the hurts
and it was a tremendous amount of
pressure put on these animals to support
that amount where you had tribes
migrating out onto the great plains and
fighting over those resources and I
think believe was one of his graduate
students later looked at this piece
where when Lewis and Clark did their big
westward journey in the early 18
hundreds,
the places where they talked about
seeing the greatest amounts where they
were just blown away by how many buffalo
they're seeing.
We're generally fa fell upon sort of no
man's lands areas between warring
tribes.
So the buffers of zone,
the buffers of traditional hunting zones
like where the blackfeet and the Su met
up the edge habitat.
There was where you had a lot of animals
that weren't getting exploited by
people.
So you started to see these like
regional extra patients of the animal
and then firearms.
What was another big blow where even
outside of white hide hunters just
showing up,
but just those,
those,
those European technologies of horse
gun.
You were seeing a a steady depletion
that would have not been in.
It seems like the resource would not
have lasted and you'd had the same
outcome.
What was interesting about his paper was
that he was saying that the early
settlers or the early explorers of the
United States in the 15 and 16 hundreds,
they didn't talk about Buffalo,
so when the Spanish,
the Spanish would go through places and
they would.
They would name wildlife now like some
of the Spanish came through,
you know,
they go through the entire Florida.
Some of the first guys have stepped foot
in Florida.
They talked about everything they see
right down to possums.
Okay.
They're not describing buffalo though.
They're describing everything else.
The English going there 200 years later
and they're talking about buffalo.
So there's sightings in what's now new
orleans.
Cabeza de Vaca ran into buffalo around
what's now Houston.
There's sightings of buffalo in what is
now Washington DC.
Simon Kenton and Daniel Boone figures
like that were hunting them around the
site of Nashville and Memphis.
They were all way to the east coast.
It seems there are only a handful of
states that at some point in time didn't
have any.
My home state of Michigan doesn't seem
like there were any for a long time.
People thought that there had been
buffalo in New York,
but it turns out the the evidence for
them and the paleontological and
archeological record is two skulls.
Both the schools have cultural markings
on them and it seems that they were the
same way that that mean in in Joe here
will like hunt an animal and bring the
head home that they might've been just
things someone had trophies that were
traded or whatever because there's no
other phone will remain from the animals
in New York,
but most places had them.
Now the mound builders,
so you have all these like mississippian
culture is along the Mississippi River
in Ohio.
River valley is called the mountain
boulders.
They made these giant effigy mounds that
people didn't even realize they were
there until we had airplanes to get
above and see the snakes and serpents
and deer and all these creatures.
They were building out our earth mounds
that were so big that guys would like
live around the mountain and never
recognize it for what it was until they
could look at it from above.
You can see these things with satellite
imagery.
They never built buffalo mounds,
but once we emptied,
and this is one argument,
kind of a Tupac argument,
once smallpox and other diseases carried
off 90 percent of native Americans,
90.
That's an estimate.
Jesus.
Many people say that.
I mean that's I,
I think it's a.
I think like the scholar,
the consensus is that it's,
that it's in that ballpark.
What are the numbers?
Do they estimate the actual physical
numbers?
You know,
I've seen it,
but I don't know what it is.
I think that there was a number that was
floating around for awhile,
10 million,
but I remember a lot of people criticize
that number as being high.
I don't know what the fashionable number
is now,
but 90 percent approximately why
diseases diseases from the Europeans and
that this was primarily responsible for
this explosion in the population,
the Buffalo.
So that's why when the Spanish would go
into places,
this is a theory now the Spanish,
we're going to places first contact,
like first peoples traipse through an
area,
they would go into places and they were
described village after village,
after village,
after village.
Okay.
And they never talked about buffalo to
English.
While later they'll go down,
someone guy,
I'll go down the Mississippi river,
he knows,
see shit for people.
But it was buffalo crawling everywhere.
Wow.
So,
and another issue,
another thing people talk about is
changing agricultural practices that
slash and burn agriculture was becoming
a used and slash and burn agriculture
was conducive to,
to,
to uh,
spreading to.
It wasn't conducive to buffalo because
it created open spaces for them.
That's another thing people look at is
slash and burn agriculture.
But either way it's proposed that the
apex of
that species was at the moment we found
the fashionable number used to be $60
million.
And that was,
that was put forth by a guy named,
you know,
Dodge city,
dodge city,
Kansas.
Got His name from a guy named Colonel
Dodge,
Colonel Dodge.
I could see,
if you're interested,
I could explain how he came up with it,
but Colonel Dodge is the one that
floated the idea that there were 60
million buffalo,
now the fashionable number is,
you know,
32 years,
$32,
million or 40 million and people say
that that was that.
That was an extraordinary amount of
those animals and we witnessed it at its
apex and that at other times in the
history of the continent and other times
with the natural history of our
continent,
there weren't nearly that many of the
animals.
Fascinating concept and I never had
heard it before.
I'd only heard that there was a giant
numbers of them and that the Europeans
came over and Americans wiped them out
because we wanted the skulls and the for
[inaudible].
We wiped out the tail end of them.
So if you get to like the end of the
day,
once you get to the end of the civil
war,
you know at that point there's maybe $15
million and that's when it was.
It was in 18,
71 and 1872 that the,
what you might call the commercial scale
harvest of the animals happened and it
happened in the south,
what was called the southern herd around
1871,
18,
72 and the area surrounding dodge city
where there's a large population of them
and then it took 10 years by 18,
82.
You couldn't find one.
Wow.
So the last big slaughter happened
around mile city,
Montana and it happened when the
railroad,
the railroad,
made it to mile city.
The northern Pacific made it to mile
city and and provided a way to get hides
the market and they did the last big
kill there and killed about a million of
them up there.
And then a year later Roosevelt came out
to Madora North Dakota there
thereabouts,
hired a guide in scoured the countryside
hunting through the carcasses of riding
animals,
trying to find one last one.
Wow.
So they could save him?
No,
he wanted to get one.
It was his epiphany.
He got to think about that guy.
He kills one and does a war dance around
it.
What kind of dances that I don't know,
I've always heard described as a war
dance who didn't Holler and dancing
around like a hunting show.
Wow.
So,
but then whatever kind of effect it had
on him,
he then went and became the most
influential conservation is we've ever
had in this country.
So it struck him somehow.
But as a young man,
yeah,
he was like,
man,
I missed it.
There's got to be one left.
So you found one.
He caught one,
killed the Montana North Dakota border
there and then.
And then went on to do all these kinds
of amazing things.
But that was,
that was the,
that was the big slaughter.
What's cool about that?
The time that worked out,
his photography was just coming out.
People were starting to have portable
cameras and there's a photographer named
La Hoffman had been sent out to miles
city and he actually took a lot of
images of those hide hunters working.
The last big hurt,
the last big shoot 'em.
And then shortly after that there was
some number animals left.
And uh,
and they lead a bunch of,
uh,
they a lot of bunch of plains Indians
to,
to leave one of the reservations and
they went and did a little bit of a mop
up.
But yeah.
Then shortly,
uh,
shortly thereafter there was a guy named
Hornaday who was kind of writing letters
around trying to find out who had one of
these things laying around because
they'd all fallen into private hands,
you know,
there's guys like buffalo hunters would
kill them and they'd be like,
Holy Shit,
there's like none left.
And some of these guys actually went out
and caught a couple.
There was a guy named Buffalo Jones down
in Texas that went out last,
sold a couple calves,
raised them on a cow's milk.
And that's how,
that's why we even have some now.
Now it turns out no one knew this,
but it turns out there was several
hundred in Canada that no one knew
about.
Really?
They didn't know about until much,
much later.
And how'd they get to Mexico?
Oh,
they probably always roamed in New
Mexico.
Now,
the first buffalo the European ever laid
eyes on was in Mexico,
now Mexico City,
but it was in,
it was in,
uh,
who is the,
the emperor there,
you know,
a
Jamie.
What was that dude's name?
The,
the Aztec leader in Mexico to notch to
notch lawn was [inaudible].
I'm Kevin.
What years?
We're talking about know in the 15
hundreds.
Cortez found one in Mexico City,
but it was in a zoo.
Montezuma?
Try saying that.
The city of topnotch salon.
Oh,
okay.
So which is in which is now Mexico City.
Uh,
they had,
he had one in a zoo.
That was the first one described by
European.
Wow.
But he was hundreds of miles away from
their native range.
They just had one,
as he had all kinds.
He had a menagerie.
He had all kinds of animals that he
collected from throughout their domains.
So that was the first one described by
European,
but he didn't realize that the time that
it was from far north of there,
but they did stray down into the,
into Sonora.
And they strayed well of all the way up.
You know,
still today we have by great slave lake,
you know,
the extent well up into Canada,
so there was a number of them,
some people call them wood buffalo,
some people accept the idea that there's
subspecies by last time about bison.
Bison,
Athabaskan,
Bison Plains Bison would bison.
There's morphological differences.
They look different.
They're in the boreal forest.
There were hundreds that we didn't know
about and know some of those populations
are still in now in Canada.
So we have,
you know,
like,
like in all things with Americans,
we have an American centric view of
everything.
We have an American centric view of
wildlife where we'll say there's only 75
left and I feel like our Canadian
neighbors are oftentimes being like,
you know what,
we didn't quite handle it quite as badly
as you folks did.
So yeah,
it was a,
you know,
it's a long,
bizarre picture.
I can't remember what the hell we get
even got us on the subject.
Uh,
Dan Flores,
uh,
I don't remember either.
Public lands,
Yellowstone Syndrome,
yellowstone brucellosis.
Yeah.
So there's a tremendous background in
the buffalo story.
Has we just explored and
w,
W,
W if you follow wildlife politics,
it's a conversation happening in places
like Alaska,
which is a whole other long story,
but how it's happening there,
it's happening in Alaska,
is happening in Montana.
It's having a Wyoming is happening in
the DAKOTAS.
Um,
which would be.
Do we welcome,
are we going to welcome this animal back
onto the landscape as a free roaming
wild animal?
Like all of our other.
Earlier I mentioned how this country,
we have an intact suite of megafauna
like we haven't lost.
We might have damn few of some things.
We haven't lost any of our large
mammals.
It's kind of mind boggling during the
colonial period.
Uh,
western Europe,
I think last five or six species of
large mammals.
The oryx many things we've,
we haven't,
we haven't lost any large mammals.
We came pretty close though,
right?
Damn calls with the buffalo in
particular.
Yeah.
And we lost.
We've lost birds.
We lost the passenger pigeon and we lost
the ivory billed woodpecker.
And you know,
we lost many things of many kinds of.
Many.
Not many,
but we've lost substantial numbers of
things we haven't lost any large mammal.
Extinction is terrifying for us.
Right.
That's one expression that a extinction
man made.
Extinction.
Yeah.
That's terrifying for me.
To me it's a,
um,
it's a moral sin
that just is like,
you know,
we have all these conversations in
bioethics and other things about playing
God.
I think that extinction like human cause
extinction is a,
it's terrifying.
Do you support if there is evidence of
human products to human caused
extinction,
if there is the opportunity to bring
something back through scientific
methods through like some sort of
cloning.
Do you support that or you think it's
gone,
it's gone,
man.
I'm on the fence about it and in my
understanding of the,
my understanding of the technology is
probably too limited for me to really
speak to it with any authority but it.
But the most interesting aspect of that
is when you get into the Pleistocene
extinctions where you notice it just
just to kind of bring people up to speed
on what that means.
If you just look globally at where we
lost that,
where we lost were in when we lost
package terms,
so elephants including the woolly
mammoth,
mastodon and in our own on our own
continent.
If you look around like where are we
last packet terms,
we always lose pack derms.
I'm right around the time show up,
know,
like we lost,
we lost them,
you know,
humans arrived in the new world.
It's a hotly debated number.
14,
15,000 years ago.
And I'm kind of contemporaneous with the
extinction of woolly mammoths and we
know that to some degree humans were
preying on wooly mammoths and mastodons.
There's context of,
of hunting equipment in context with,
with wooly,
mammoth remains.
There's butchering sites,
there's all kinds of stuff.
And they vanished right around then,
um,
yet we didn't reach an island out in the
Bering Sea till 4,000 years ago and
there was a woolly mammoth on that
island till 4,000 years ago.
And then dudes show up.
It's gone.
So some people will look,
there's a thing called the blitzkrieg
hypothesis,
which hold that all these large mammals
though,
nine general of large mammals that went
extinct when humans arrived in the new
world that they were somehow human
caused extinctions.
Not other people argue that it was,
you know,
other things,
climate change issues.
Randall Carlson is a guy who I've had on
my podcast before and he argues that
it's due to asteroidal impacts.
Yeah.
I hung out with a guy who's doing
research on that and there's a lot of
evidence of evidence.
This guy was looking for nano diamonds.
Guy Found namel domain or diamonds,
I think you say it's called Triton
night,
but it's nuclear glass.
It's the same exact glass that they get
on sand when they have nuclear
explosions.
When they do test sites,
they find that all throughout Europe and
it's all around 12,000 years and there's
also more,
somewhere around 10,000.
So it seems like somewhere between
12,000 and then another thousand years
or so later there was another series of
impacts.
And it has to do with this,
uh,
asteroid belt that we pass through.
And it was fucking fascinating but
terrifying conversation with.
I went with a guy that,
there's a,
there's a famous,
uh,
Paleoindian site,
north of Denver called the Linden Meyer
site and the Linda Meyer site was one of
the few,
not one of the only place that we now
know were large gatherings of the,
of the folsom culture,
a large gatherings of the folsom culture
where you had perhaps hundreds of folsom
hunters in one place at one time and the
site is marked by a larger,
like a,
like an easily recognizable escarpment.
And it's,
it's presumed that it was just a place
that you could describe and people could
meet up.
But that's the,
the Linden Meyer site has been studied
extensively in tons of radiocarbon
dating has happened at Linden Meyer
site.
And I was with a guy there who was
looking,
who is working on that theory.
Then you know,
the theory with the,
the asteroid impact and the nano
diamonds,
because he was able to go draw samples
from strata that had been tested and
studied so much,
which is an expensive laborious process
to get datelines,
you know,
when he was there,
drawn those things out.
And then I had other people who,
who worked professionally in this space
talking about how um,
because sorta ridiculing idea
and saying that it's just like one of
these ideas that never dies and I'm
never quite lives but never quite dies.
And,
and uh,
but when you look at it,
it's just so hard to believe that they
hunted them to extinction so quickly.
Well,
the many things,
65 percent of all the North American
mammals died really quickly and it
wasn't just big stuff.
Yeah.
The thing is like we use it because when
we used to do digs,
right,
they used to do like archeological digs,
you know,
they would use high pressure hoses and
shit.
And they were,
they only had an.
They're only looking at the big stuff,
but many,
many things went extinct.
Did you see that bird species?
Small species,
you know,
it's,
it's Kinda hard to picture it.
It's just so hard to picture what
exactly happened.
It's just,
I don't know,
especially in people killing them with
adult adults.
Yeah.
Those goofy things.
Which I mean,
how far can you throw an Atlatl,
uh,
that people kill stuff?
Forty yards.
I think that's a real phrase.
It'd be like the hulk,
but then the thing they say is,
you know,
we talked about wildlife in yellowstone
being habituated.
That wildlife probably would have been
the other extreme.
They probably would have been like,
uh,
the elk in yellowstone wolves showed up.
Was it like,
Whoa,
what's that cute dog?
Right.
So,
and then they have very low fecundity,
you know,
pack in terms of we're not just talking
about,
that's a problem.
We're just talking about packing or
you're talking about like a short faced
bears,
the American Cheetah,
giant ground sloths on and on and on and
on and on to these guys really hunted to
extinction.
It's hard to imagine but it's also hard
to imagine all that shit going to
extinct for any cause.
Well its also coincides with the end of
the ice age,
so something happened.
Something radical at the end of the ice
age is just an idea that we've created,
right?
Like we did during.
There were interglacial periods,
like if you look at the ice ages are or
the pleistocene,
right?
There were interglacial periods where
the water was much higher than it is
now.
There were interglacial periods when the
water would have been up over the
pedestal of the Statue of Liberty
Really?
And then shit froze again as like.
But the idea that the pleistocene
holocene transition is just like a.
it's just a point we divided in our
heads,
you know,
we had,
there was many glaciations right?
Time will only tell if we ever see
another glaciation again,
but I don't know.
And that's one of the things that,
that's one of the things that makes that
emboldens people who contradict.
One of the things that emboldens people
who contradict human caused climate
change is that we've been through so
many cycles,
they'll often point out and say,
well,
how do we know this isn't just a normal,
another warming trend between ice age
periods and then a lot of people pointed
out and go because there's no evidence
that they ever happened this quickly.
This is like radically fast.
These are things that played out over
10,000 years.
These aren't things that played out over
human lifetimes.
You know,
an interglacial period being a 10,000
year thing.
Interestingly,
interglacial periods are really
important to understanding all these
issues because interglacial periods in
glacial periods,
mark moments when wildlife could have
come into the new world when wildlife
such as you know,
buffalo and then later elk and other
things when they would have had the
opportunity to come from Asia and
crossed the bering land bridge and come
down and do our to our continent and
when it would have,
when they could have not done that.
So when you look at like when did humans
show up?
When did these other things show up?
Like when did the horses disappeared?
When could they have come down?
One [inaudible] buffalo come down.
How did elk get here?
You're sort of always looking at
assuming they didn't come down when the
entire north of swerved and 40 feet of
snow and ice,
presuming they came down when it was the
icefree corridor and so you can kind of
fine tune all these comings and goings,
but looking at moments when there was an
ice record or to come down and so if
it's beautifully intertwined,
man,
it's so complex and there's no way to
really lock it down yet has no way to
really.
Totally figured it out yet.
But it's so fascinating when they find
these animals still.
They just pulled a big giant skull with
tusks out of a ranch in Montana.
Like really recently.
I think I tweeted it,
I think it was c,
see if you could find it on
my body.
Found a jaw with the maulers in it,
but
to museum.
Wow.
He just found a couple of years ago he
found it in the tone.
My friend John,
his buddy owns a ranch in Montana and he
was talking to some.
This might be the same guy.
Do you know where it was?
No,
I don't know,
but this was.
I'm talking about the tusks.
Oh,
nevermind.
Okay.
They,
they,
they found a dinosaur on his property.
Said the,
uh,
archaeologists came.
What was it?
A paleontologist?
Paleontologist paleontologist came to
his property.
He said he went for a walk up the hill.
He stopped.
He found something on the ground.
He looked around,
he made some calculations and it came
back to him.
He goes,
congratulations.
You got a dinosaur on your property.
He was what?
They came back.
They have a fucking t-rex on his
property.
No one guy got a million and a half
dollars because they pulled a fucking
t-rex from his property for the
paleontologist,
found it,
and literally founded in five minutes,
said he started walking around the
property.
He found a tooth or some sort of chip,
a piece of bone.
He recognized it immediately as being
dinosaur.
Made some phone calls,
called some people and next thing you
know,
like within weeks they had started
excavations.
No shit found a fucking t rex and I was
prepping cars because it was on private
land.
You could sell it a million and a half
dollars on
public land Foa.
Once something's fossilized,
you can't touch it.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
But do I agree?
Cause I don't want to escape your
question about
undoing human caused extinctions.
What else getting at is the animals that
I'm most interested in just from a boy
in a very boyish way.
Are those pleistocene creditors.
Um,
and if I knew,
you know,
if I had the diamond and bullet right
there would tell me that.
Yes,
absolutely.
We lost the mammoth because of human
hunting behaviors at the pleistocene
holocene transition.
I will be like,
let's bring them sons of bitches back
right now.
Wow.
If you could prove without a shadow of a
doubt that human hunters created that
problem.
Yeah.
And I knew the tech,
like,
let's say the technology was just fail
safe.
You want to talk about some
controversial.
You think people are up in arms about
some buffalo hunting around you cut
loose them short faced bears or you
know,
that would be a giant issue.
Yeah.
You think the wolf reintroduction when
she was shaky?
The short face bear,
the scary guy.
They have animal.
That's a huge bear very fast.
Really?
Yeah.
They,
they were,
they were a fast runner and they're
bigger than polar bears.
And you know,
there's a,
the American Cheetah.
Yeah.
That's the reason why antelope are so
fast.
That's a theory that the antelope are
ridiculously fast for any predator.
There's like,
there's speed doesn't make sense through
the context of what's chasing them right
now.
Why do people call them speed goats
while they haul.
But why goat?
Because.
Because there I think there's a,
there's a,
there's a dumb ass reason and there's a
tax nonvocal reason and I know dear
friends of mine on both sides of that
spectrum where I'm fast,
if I put it to my brother who on
occasion calls him goats,
he'll talk about how taxonomically
there,
uh,
you know,
they're distinct.
Like they're the only thing in there.
They're the only thing in their family,
right?
Um,
they don't have any close relatives,
but there,
there,
there are only there a horned animal
that sheds its horns and antlers shed
elk,
Moose,
deer.
All the servants like antler shed horns
don't shed.
Animals carry their horns for their
whole life.
Like a Kraton a sheath.
But antelope shed their horn.
But it turns out that some people like
to point out that they're like a close
to a goat.
The goat is close.
Other people say just because they kind
of looked like goats.
I don't know.
I think it's a derogatory term.
I don't like it really.
I don't like derogatory animal terms.
The why is goat a derogatory tone?
Well,
go is what people call the greatest of
all time.
It's the goat.
Now a mountain goat is a noble,
majestic animal,
right?
A barnyard go.
I don't think it's noble and Majesta.
Okay.
And I don't think they're equating it to
a mountain goat,
right?
The mountain go.
Being as beautiful white,
fluffy goats will be in a wild animal.
Those are awesome.
Yeah.
It's a wild animal.
And to be like a speed go,
you're saying like,
oh,
it's like a goat,
a lowly barnyard.
Go that hauls ass.
I was just in his act.
I feel that this derogatory.
This is a minor issue.
I'll point out.
But it does bother me.
I don't think it's derogatory to call it
a go.
But I do think that.
And I haven't met whatever it does.
I haven't met anyone who does think it's
derogatory.
But it's so funny because mountain goat,
you agree as a noble animal.
I don't want to you.
I was in Hawaiian culture everywhere.
Bizarre.
Driving down the road.
It's fucking goats everywhere.
Which just wild goats.
And they're like,
they're like a wild animal.
Yeah man.
You already talked about wildlife
politics.
Hawaii.
Hm?
Do you ever want to get into that?
Yeah,
it's crazy.
That's interesting shit.
Where you have your whole suite of
mammals is,
uh,
your whole suite of mammals is all non
native.
Yeah,
all of them.
But here's the,
here's where it's interesting.
So polynesians colonize the Hawaiian
islands,
like the first people,
the first humans to colonize the
Hawaiian islands.
Polynesians who carried with them rats.
Dogs,
pigs,
right.
We have native Hawaiians,
right?
Like Hawaiians and indigenous Hawaiians.
People are carrying native rights.
They regard themselves as native
Hawaiians.
Yet people are always telling them that
the wildlife is non native,
so you get people that showed up with
pigs and now the nature conservancy will
get chunks of land in Hawaii and
eradicate the non natives and the native
Hawaiians be like,
but were contemporaneous with these
animals.
How am I native?
Right,
but you're telling me that the thing I
like to hunt is not native.
It needs to be gotten rid of.
It's ridiculous.
They should think it is.
Well,
I don't mean to say they like.
It's a unanimously held viewpoint,
but people who hold the viewpoint of
that,
they that they hunt pigs,
their father hunt pigs,
their grandfather hump pigs.
They're great.
Great,
great,
great.
Great grandfather,
hundred pigs.
Now what's the pressure coming from to
eradicate them from agriculture?
No,
it's from people who who are worried
about losing yet more and we've already
lost,
doesn't know.
Speaking regional extinctions are extra
patients and in some cases extinction
extinction.
We've lost dozens of species of,
of Hawaiian Flora and fauna to
considering a wide range of ground
nesting birds have been lost to rats and
pigs.
So now it's not so much focused on the
animals but,
but flora,
so there are people who are trying to
read who would like to,
and then I get where they're coming
from,
who would like to restore,
um,
large areas of,
of native
plant communities in the Hawaiian
islands because anything,
when you go there,
all the fruit you see the coconuts are
not native papayas,
mangoes,
breadfruit,
none of that stuff's native.
Wow.
It's all introduced.
It's a p that places a petri dish,
man.
They got their turkeys,
pheasants,
chucker,
they're hunting access and everything
there.
But none of that shit's from there.
So there are some people who look and
they say like,
we have,
uh,
you know,
ecological responsibility to try to
salvage some part of this.
But meanwhile,
another perspective would be like,
we made this place bloom,
this place oozes with life.
And there's people who,
you know,
they get all their,
they're able to glean all of their
food sources from the island,
from things that their ancestors have
established on the island,
and it's offensive to them.
Do you know about Darwin visiting the
Galapagos silence and that it's one of
the ways that he sort of formulated his
theories about evolution and all the
various variety of wildlife,
uh,
through visiting the Galapagos islands
unintentionally.
People have had seeds that they brought
with them on the bottom of their shoes.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Which is really crazy.
And all these animals and plants are
either are growing that are non native
and this debate pops up as to what to do
with them.
And then there's all these turtles that
live there and there's this debate props
up as to like how to protect these
turtles.
And they brought in goats to eradicate
some of the,
some of the plants now.
And there's some people brought goats
over there,
like some sailors,
brock goats over there as a food source
and left them on the island figuring,
hey,
we'll stop back when we need food.
And now they've got goat problems,
so they're trying to figure out how to
eradicate the goats.
And
you know,
the Judas,
Judas goat.
That's good.
Well they take one goat and they,
uh,
they sterilize that goat and so that
goat can't breed,
but that goat will find all the other
goats and hang out with that goat and
they put a radio collar on the little
fucker and then he lets them know where
the other goats are and then they gunned
down those goats
and he goes,
well,
I to go find some other goats.
And he goes and finds the other one.
And they're like,
oh,
we found him.
And the thing is the poor guy,
I don't even know if he's like,
he's like,
man,
am I lucky they show up in his
helicopter that,
that,
that may have taken them out like
platoon style.
Yo,
the writer,
Tom Robbins,
um,
is he still alive?
Skinny legs and all.
I think he jitterbug perfume.
Yeah,
I think he's alive.
You know,
he was talking about.
And one of his books,
he talks about Hawaii,
how Hawaii had a rat problem.
Then they brought in the mongoose and
they had a mongoose problem and he makes
the joke that we had a crime problem and
we brought in cops.
Well that's sort of what Australia did.
Australia brought in Fox to deal with
the rabbits.
They brought in rabbits.
The rabbits got out of control.
They brought in Fox and deal with the
rabbits,
the Fox already in ground nesting birds.
And they brought in cats as well.
They have a huge feral cat problem in
Australia to the point where they're
hunting magazines are really bizarre
because holding up cats like what?
Like my friend Adam Green tree lives in
Australia and you know,
it's,
it's a crazy place because it's similar
in a lot of ways that Hawaii is,
that a lot of the animals they or not
native,
but they're hunting magazines are filled
with fucking dogs and cats and shit.
It's just weird to literally shaken up
Mary if you left one of those on an
airplane.
So the next passenger to find while I
was on an airplane and uh,
I got to the part where the guy was
holding up the cat grip and grin and I
just turned the page real quick.
Come
on.
Fucking Jesus is heavy.
Yeah.
The non native thing is,
uh,
it,
it amazes me.
Our inability
to anticipate,
or I guess it's Kang.
I'm going to say something.
It's like weirdly contradictory,
our inability to anticipate unintended
consequences,
which doesn't entirely make sense,
but you see what I'm getting at.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Well there's no forethought to bring in
boxes or cats like and say,
well they're just gonna eat the rabbit
that we left behind.
Yeah.
Had Your fucking mind.
They're gonna eat everything.
I kid you not see that coming.
Don't you know what a cat does?
No.
That's killed things.
You can't even throw a ball of yarn in
front of a fucking.
Yeah.
I mean,
it Kinda doesn't end like we're doing.
We're doing it now.
Something we just don't.
We won't know yet.
In 10 years we'll be there 20 years.
We'll be goofing on.
Something we're doing right now that we
think is a good idea probably,
right?
Yeah.
Well we like.
Can you believe those dumb asses?
Yeah.
In 2016 thought x,
I have some theories about what those
things might be,
but I mean,
you know,
we're not done
well.
Commercial sales,
commercial,
large scale agriculture in a way is not
only just really,
really recent.
It's completely unnatural to have these
giant swaths of land.
It's filled with corn.
Yeah.
Like monoculture stuff's very unnatural.
So people that think about like,
oh,
I'm,
you know,
I'm eating vegetables,
I'm eating natural and I'm not a part of
this whole factory farm system.
What the fuck?
You're not.
You're a part of factory agriculture
system.
If you're eating corn,
if you're buying corn,
you're eating corn on the cob thinking
you're all healthy.
That shit is coming from a really
unnatural place.
It's coming from this ground that has
been filled up with all this nitrogen
that's been sucked out of the air
through the harbor method.
They've,
they've dumped it into the earth because
the earth earth's been depleted with
minerals to the point where they're no
longer supports growth of plants unless
you add stuff to it and then you have
these large scale machines that they
need to attend to this stuff.
And there's nothing natural about large
scale agriculture.
No,
we just don't consider it because we
consider factory farming when it comes
to living animals as being horrific,
you know,
whether it's pigs or cows or chickens,
that disturbs almost anybody with a
conscience,
but we don't think twice about the
consequences of large scale agriculture
on actual wildlife and wild
when you picture that we have,
I mean much vaster than this,
but we have entire counties that support
a single species of plant of plant.
Oftentimes a single species of a non
native plant.
Corn.
Corn is.
It's kind of a native,
you know,
it's derived from maze.
It's like kind of a native species.
So oftentimes it's like entire county's
given over to a single non native plant.
Well isn't corn sort of like looking at
a domestic dog and saying,
well that domestic dog as
a wild animal?
Yeah,
I really,
I,
I don't even know,
like if you took someone from
pre-colombian times and showed them a
corn cob,
I don't know that they,
they,
I don't think that they would probably
recognize that.
You wouldn't know what the fuck that
was.
They were dealing with a corn that was
more.
It was.
That was a smaller than when you are
making a stir fry and get the little
baby corn things,
whether that's small,
small,
little things.
Yeah.
Wow.
They can't even tell like they can't
tell how it even came to be.
Some people have a theory that it was
bred from a grass.
It's like they're like the lineage of
corn is hard to track.
Wow.
So was this native Americans that did
this where they figured out how to
splice these plants together and tie.
There's a book,
I can't remember the name of the book
that gets into it,
but just trying to like track down sort
of the history of corn and how it came
to be.
You know,
the oftentimes points you would
domestication of animals and plants.
Sometimes it was sort of an accidental
domestication,
you know,
like you'd go out and gather something,
right,
and you bring it home,
you process it near your home,
you're scattering seed,
right?
And eventually you're like creating
these things.
But yeah,
corns,
difficult to track the lineage of corn
is not clear.
It's just so bizarre what kind of a
foothold it has an American culture to
everything,
man.
It's,
everything's crazy.
I recently interviewed for a documentary
project we're working on.
I interviewed a animal he's at,
he's from California.
He's an animal rights activist and a,
he's a,
he teaches animal ethics and um,
he has a brand of veganism that I think
it would be refreshing to.
You should have this guy.
I keep telling him you should have on
your show.
But,
uh,
he has a barrier.
What's his name?
His name's Robert Jones.
He has a very,
uh,
refreshing sort of veganism.
I'd had this dude over dinner.
Really?
Yeah.
But,
but,
but he,
he doesn't,
he doesn't hold out ideas that he's peer
because of what we're talking about
right.
Like he's,
he's educated enough about agriculture
and educated enough about the inherent
struggle,
the inherent life and death through all
food production did.
He doesn't think like,
oh,
I have all the answers.
I am the gentle kind one because he's
seen cornfields like he knows like
you're churning your violently churning
the land with the equipment.
Things are dying when you grow
vegetables like we're in,
we're in meshed in a in a cycle of life
and death.
That is inescapable.
His point,
we're not on.
I don't want to totally steal the guy's
pointing.
He'd do a better job explain himself,
but his point is that if we agree that
we should minimize suffering,
right?
There are steps we can take to minimize
suffering.
Not Saying that I've got it.
Answer is no,
I've got it figured out,
but if we want to minimize the suffering
of sentient beings,
then that's a conversation we should
have.
The best thing that he said,
the best thing that he said in
explaining the animal rights movement,
which I've always been a little bit
baffled by,
is he gets into this idea of he uses the
term speciesism.
Yeah.
I've heard that one.
So you know,
we had,
we've dealt with and deal with racism
we've dealt with and deal with sexism
and we are,
he would argue,
I think he would say we're on the cusp
of,
of tackling our problem with speciesism
and he would say like if you went to
someone like,
you know,
if you went to the Mississippi Delta,
in the,
in the 17 and late 17 hundreds and said
to someone like,
Hey,
you know,
have you ever thought about the fact
that uh,
you know,
you kind of like own and abuse these
people.
Have you ever thought about how they're
like people too,
you know,
they're like you and me.
He was,
he was saying like,
the guy wouldn't be able to cope with
what you were saying.
He'd be like,
oh,
clearly.
I mean,
come on,
any idiot could tell you that that slave
is not.
I mean,
come on.
Right,
right.
He says,
that's where we're at right now with
animals.
Like when I say it to you,
you're like,
well,
clearly we're so.
Does he aim to stop animal on animal
crime?
You know,
I asked him about that and um,
that was one of the things that I,
at the end of our conversation,
I even said to him,
I'm like,
you got a couple of things you need to
work on because he didn't have a great
one for that.
Another one that he didn't have a great
one for his.
He had
nothing to,
not that he ended a great one now that I
was like trying to stump him because
he's,
he's a very intelligent,
well thought person and very respectful
to people that you talking.
Do even people that disagree with them.
I have nothing but admiration for the
guy.
But we had a,
a conversation that,
that I,
that I was not totally satisfied with
where he has a deal of reverence it
seems.
And again,
at the risk of putting words in his
mouth,
he has a reverence for like indigenous
hunting cultures,
right?
That they had like this sort of respect.
They had a respect for animals that we
don't have and somehow that made it okay
for them.
Like they had a spiritual connection.
And so that made that okay.
And we don't have that,
so we're not okay.
And I asked them about are you able to
identify the point in human development
and cultural development?
What is the point when you're supposed
to give up the chase?
Like at what point do you have a
responsibility to stop hunting because
you're saying that it is okay.
For some people it's absolutely not okay
for us now when should we have made the
jump?
Because earlier Tom Bout like the
Spanish,
there's a.
there's a situation where the Spanish
had gone into in the American southwest
and we're trying to,
as they called it civilize southwestern
tribes and they were building homes for
them,
trying to instruct them in religion,
trying to create schools for them,
trying to provide them with
the tools of the agrarian lifestyle.
And they would write letters back to the
king complaining about how these people
refuse to stop,
go hunting.
Like you give them a chance and he sons
of bitches take off to go hunt and here
we are giving them everything they need
to be sedentary and they just won't get
with the program.
So there is this struggle where people
were like,
you're supposed to be like,
I think some people expect you,
like if you're a human,
they think that the end result of
humanness is that you like wind up not
hunting,
that it's sort of the goal of
civilizations to make you not a hunter.
And I think he's a little bit guilty of
that because he thinks it is okay for
some people and where he runs into
trouble.
As he talks about that.
I asked him about ethics.
He says,
but the animal doesn't care about your
ethics to him.
He's dying.
If he dies and you have a good feeling
in your heart or if he dies and you have
a bad feeling in your heart,
he's dead.
It doesn't matter.
They don't know what trip you're on your
car.
They suffer the same regardless of your
motivations.
And which leads me to want to point out,
okay,
but the indigenous cultures that you
say,
it's okay for them to hunt.
Their animals are suffering to the
animals they killed.
Don't know that they're being killed by
indigenous peoples and therefore it
makes the suffering more palatable for
them.
They're dying.
So there are some traps there that,
that,
that to me were answered in a
satisfactory way.
Does any of that make sense?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a very messy situation if you want
to try to confine behavior that way and
you want to impart moral judgment on
people because what do you do with
people with pets?
We do it.
People that have cats.
I mean he has,
he has companion animals.
He has some very good.
He has good stuff to say about that.
Yeah,
it was very interesting.
So saved.
What does you have to say with those
animals that are mistreated and confined
and ground up in the food?
He wouldn't like that,
but I,
I don't know if you feel.
I,
I would imagine,
um,
I feel,
I feel kind of like you can feed your
cats,
have a vegan diet and I would imagine in
my act about it because I got into it
because I found out I got,
I got harassed by someone online and I
went to their twitter page and it said
Hashtag Vegan cat and I went,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
And then I found this entire community
of people that feed their cats vegan
food.
The problem is the cats go blind.
They die
like that.
He didn't,
he wasn't that interested in an
argument.
And when I was saying to him like,
would you,
do you feel that we should separate
predatory animals from pray and put them
on like a soy diet?
And he just thought I'll.
And I don't understand why he felt that
was being like ridiculous for the sake.
Well it is,
but how you're going to see those stats.
It's a real quick question.
I mean,
why you,
you're,
you're taking this cat and you're
putting this cat above the animals that
it eats.
Your deciding that these chickens and
the fish and all the different things
that you need to grind up to make cat
food.
That's okay because you love this cat.
You have a hierarchy of animal life and
we all have a hierarchy of life.
Vegans.
I've seen
vegans slap mosquitoes.
I've seen it.
I've seen that.
I've seen them kill ants.
You know,
there was a lady I used to live near
[inaudible].
The lady that ran the Ashram was
spraying bug spray with the from.
It's a Buddhist temple.
It's okay.
And she was still live in a house next
to it.
Oh,
next door to it,
sorry.
Um,
and um,
she used to spray bug spray on the ants
and I was like,
what the fuck you on the ant on the
answer to kill the ants.
She was killing him and I go,
what are you doing?
She's like,
well,
we don't like to.
But they get into our food and like,
Holy Shit,
like you're a vegetarian who's committed
to a Buddhist life of do no harm,
but yet you're,
there's no way around this.
You have to poison these fucking ends
with death from the sky that comes out
of these containers.
These metal containers is aerosol
containers of death.
This is,
but this is a bizarre lines that we
draw,
but as long as I am putting my,
uh,
taken the liberty of putting myself in
Robert and Joe and Wethis is Robert
Jones,
his position,
I think that he would have some
interesting stuff to say about,
about this conversation we're having
when we're like,
because some harm happens.
Then let's just say fuck it,
and we'll open up the gates.
Well,
no,
but let's talk about life.
Is his life in a small form more
insignificant or less significant than
an elk?
Like,
who decides that an ant is less
significant than an hour?
If I shoot one elk,
I can eat it for a year.
That's one life,
one life for a year.
You don't like ants getting on your
peanut butter and Jelly Sandwich.
So you spray a whole colony of these
fuckers.
You've killed thousands of life forces.
And even ruling out the insect thing.
I've ever,
uh,
a guy that wrote a,
a pretty scathing review.
I think he might've been,
it might've been.
I came,
remember it was in the Wall Street
Journal or somewhere you,
this guy wrote a pretty scathing review
of my third book and,
and there is like just the number of
animals this guy has killed about me.
Right.
I remember thinking if you go and get a
12 pack of mcnuggets,
how many chickens,
how you sorted out the parts,
you're probably eating hundreds of
chickens probably.
Yeah.
There's,
it's all scraps.
It's emulsified.
Scrap.
Yeah.
They're not like,
okay,
we're going to take this chicken here
and we're going to produce 30 nuggets.
Well,
my problem is they never turned that
force on themselves.
They never turned that high powered
vision of,
you know,
the consequences of their actions on
themselves.
If someone's talking about like,
if this guy is a Vegan and he's a
vegetarian and he's talking about how
many animals you've killed,
how many animals are you responsible
for,
for your fucking,
your whole wheat.
He wasn't even,
he wasn't he.
He was.
So he was a mediator.
Well,
that's preposterous.
That's Ricky Gervais'.
It's Ricky Gervais' constantly talks
hunters
and hunting the guy who eats meat,
like there's so many weird laws and I,
I get it that he doesn't think people
should hunt animals just for trophies.
And I agree,
but it's very rarely do these animals
get hunted just for trophies.
Like can you,
if you shoot a fucking elephant,
the village eats the elephant when
you're feeding hundreds of people with
that elephant.
And I'll point out too,
and I do all the time pro elephant
shooting.
It's illegal.
No,
I,
I like,
we're going to talk about yellowstone
syndrome.
I almost,
I'm almost having a personal.
I'm,
I'm almost,
I'm taking a couple year long break from
discussing wildlife in Africa.
Really just black
now.
The your article that you wrote was one
of my favorite on that subject and it
was right around the time that the
Cecil,
the lion thing was going down and it
also referenced that Kendall Jones girl
who uh,
got a lot of hate online because she
had,
she was a Texas cheerleader and she was
really cute and I think
yeah,
people hate a good looking woman hunting
in Africa.
Big Smile on her face and do not.
They do not like some dude,
like did a real good and heating and
cooling and like my hands aren't going
to go a lot.
People are like,
yeah,
that's fucking cool.
Hot Girls.
Hot American girls don't go there.
Well,
and it's also like,
what are you shooting?
If you're over there and you're shooting
a Kudu and you're going to eat it and
you know,
you feed the villages every as well.
It is an antelope that's okay.
This is traditional.
Something that we owe.
We're going to talk about the hierarchy
because we spent a lot of time at work
work when we're out filming mediator.
We spent a lot of time talking about the
hierarchy because for instance,
we have a camera guy who worked with
Rick Smith,
has a long professional history and
working with wildlife,
filming wildlife and uh,
didn't grow up hunting.
Um,
he,
he's coming around,
he's curious about it,
but he asked a lot of good questions and
we were looking.
We had killed a Moose and um,
the next day it happened.
We were up in,
uh,
in Alaska.
We killed a moose in the next day.
We rolled our camp and having to go near
there and there was a wolverine dragging
off Moose parts when you talked about
this on your podcast.
Yeah,
it's great story.
Rick was like,
and you're allowed in that area between
September one and March 31st you're
allowed to kill your lot.
Oh,
Wolverine.
Um,
and my friend bought boat and you know,
he,
he has eaten and enjoys wolverine meat
and the hides,
as we all know what phenomenal the
height.
I don't think we all know that well,
digital listening to this,
like we all know traditionally parkers
are trimmed with Wolverine because
Wolverine will not freeze up when Scott
Frost on it by trim,
demean the,
around the hood,
around the hood.
When your exhale and you're.
Yeah,
stuff gets fraud.
Will Ring.
Doesn't frost up.
Wow.
So is that going to be used?
I don't know.
I don't know why it was a hollow hair,
but I don't know what it is about it
that it resists.
This fraud resists for us.
So anyways,
we're kicking around.
I'll,
I'll tell the end.
First day we didn't shoot the bull ring
but we were just about,
you know,
we legally could have gone and take a
crack at it.
Did you have an opportunity to do so?
Yeah,
we would have had to have acted quickly,
but yes.
Or You could have staked it out and just
waited for him to come back because he
wanted to.
He's a little thief.
He's stealing your Moose,
but we already butchered it.
Right.
He was taking the hooves.
Oh,
okay.
Guts.
Right.
But you're a leader,
so he's taken bone.
He actually stole two our marathons
because we then have the fucker cause
he,
we took,
we took the four big marrow bones and he
wound up getting over on another night
at dark and stoled some of our marrow
bones out of our cash.
But we didn't see it happen.
Anyhow,
Rick's point now,
I don't think you should mess with like,
he's like,
that's an animal that I think is off and
we're like,
why is that?
He's like,
well,
they Rome.
One of the things he was talking about,
he was like,
man,
they cover so much ground.
You know,
they'll have a home range,
you know,
they'll go 250 miles.
It's like,
yeah,
but we just killed a Caribou and Caribou
go a thousand miles hundreds of miles.
So it's not distance traveled.
No,
it's just a,
it's just something,
you know.
It's like,
yeah,
it's just something.
Well,
people are pairs,
of course.
The way you describe it.
Charismatic megafauna.
Yeah,
that's,
that's not my term,
but it's a great.
I hats off to whoever did.
I'm sure you could find out who invented
the charismatic megafauna there's
attributed to you.
So I'm going to leave it with,
you know,
I didn't come up with it.
I heard a linguist one day.
You could find it.
Hurdle linguists one day talking about,
uh,
he,
he was interested in tracking where
things come from.
That would be an easy case,
but you know,
what he was interested in tracking was a
waitresses saying,
are you still working on that?
Because there was a time when no one
said that and then all of a sudden
everyone said it
and he was interested.
Where did,
are you still working on that?
Come from the one mouth that it first
came out of.
So yeah,
I didn't know.
Charismatic megaphone is great and I
think that there's some things are so
charismatic wolves and grizzlies that
like New Jersey cat ladies know about
them.
Did you see that?
The,
the billboard that they were all cecil,
there was a lion hugging a bear that was
trying to stop the bear hunt in New
Jersey.
No,
he never saw it.
I know that you don't even guy someone,
you know,
the pedals,
the bear as Sherman's shot pedals.
How rude.
Like whenever something like that
happens.
Man,
I remember reading it.
I read it right when I,
right when it came out like a fish and
game agency.
They're just a little background is a
bear.
Is there kind of a neighborhood bear in
New Jersey?
And he had had some kind of injury or
uh,
possibly birth defect where he wasn't
able to.
He spent a lot of time walking bipedaly
yeah.
Um,
which is not uncommon,
which is probably when he had his,
he had obvious injuries in his front
section.
So would,
would walk.
Yeah.
Debbie,
not uncommon and probably,
you know,
it could be a lot of the things we have
about harming,
you know,
like,
like large,
mysterious and it's could come from,
you know,
obviously bears walking around their
back feet.
But you know,
New Jersey had their.
Have they haven't,
I don't want to say I don't want to have
this mean too many,
but they have a exploding population of
black.
I'm always reluctant to say something's
overpopulated because you always got to
ask like according to whose definition
is it,
like the automobile insurance comp
industry,
because they'll say everything's over
populated that you might run over with
your car.
Agricultural interests have a different
definition of overpopulated,
so they have a shitload of bears.
That's a fair statement.
They had a hunting season.
Turns out some guy comes into a check
station and he had shot this bear that
walks around on his back feet and they'd
given him the name pedals because he'd
taken two scavenging bird feeders and
stuff around the neighborhood.
And um,
so I can't remember the magazine,
one of those,
one of those dip shitty a New York
online magazines and just basically
coles basically steals shit out of the
New York Times and writes its own
interpretations of New York Times
articles.
Wasn't Gawk or something like that.
Said that pedals had been assassinated?
Yes.
Oh,
I read that.
But what are those websites that all
they do is like hack on traditional
media,
but then they just write articles
commenting on traditional media stories.
Yeah,
but they're not generating leads.
Let's look at this billboard ban the
bear hunt.
Bear all seesaw.
They're crying,
they're crying,
they have cartoon tears like literal and
look how the bears hugging or the line
rather is hugging the bear.
Poor babies.
Yeah.
That's a nice billboard.
Um,
what,
what about pedals?
Oh,
the people that get the charismatic
megafauna because another that we talked
about,
our podcast recently,
we had a biologist on,
um,
who works for the Kalispell tribe,
you know,
Indian tribe and that historically you
were in Idaho portions of Washington and
portions of Montana.
Um,
and they're very involved and Caribou
Mountain Caribou recovery in the US.
So most people do not know that.
Um,
traditional,
traditional.
We had a Caribou population that drifted
down from,
drifted from Canada down into northern
Washington,
northern Idaho,
northwest Montana.
We don't have that now at all.
Well,
it was about a dozen of them.
Okay.
Right at this moment that we're talking
right now,
there are some,
a couple miles from the US border inside
Canada,
but there used to be the last legal one
to be killed wasn't.
It was back in the 19 twenties.
What happened in was just disturbances
that habitat,
um,
uh,
there was always a small,
not a large number of them and we had a
lot of things that mess with their
travel corridors,
development road,
construction,
logging activities and now they,
they rarely ever drift down into the US,
but as an active recovery area there.
So we got about a dozen Caribou that are
contenders to be in theU ,
s net sometimes we'll actually crossed
and come into the US in the selkirk
mountains.
No one gives a shit
about mountain Caribou.
The amount of like energy,
the amount of mental energy that goes
into people's favorite animals
at the expense of other good projects.
We could be other good wildlife projects
we could be working on.
Kind of boggles my mind.
Black bears you have.
So we have enough black bears that we
have black bear hunting seasons and I
think 36 states.
Wow.
Rapidly expanding population of black
bears and people will spend enormous
amounts of energy and resources because
it's like I don't understand it and
they're just.
And they just like are willfully
ignorant about other wildlife issues
that are much more important because
it's like,
it's not cuddly.
It doesn't look fuzzy.
Well,
they don't have a stuffed one.
I don't know what it is.
Stuffed Teddy bears.
There's a lot of it.
The what
we,
we've gotten accustomed to thinking of
these things is our friends.
It's Yogi bear.
We,
we've done these anthropomorphization
with these cartoons and television shows
and it's ingrained in the consciousness
of a lot of people.
No matter what you do,
you can't get it out of there.
There's,
there's some legitimate differences
between animals.
You know,
we were talking about that yesterday.
We were talking about the differences
between bears and deer.
Like deer looks at you in a bear,
looks at you.
You know about how when I was talking
before the show about whitetail deer,
it's like catching the other day.
You in a way,
nothing has ever looked at.
Look at you.
That's their electric.
Their eyes are like,
they like,
no,
you're there to kill them.
And they're like,
oh,
that's fucking person.
I've got to get out of hand.
Or a bear looks at you like going on
here,
can I eat you?
Can you eat me?
You know,
there's like a weird sort of
relationship that people have with
bears.
Like they look at you and.
But they don't look at you with the same
sort of intense fear that a game animal
looks at you.
Yeah.
There's this blurring of the lines there
and I think that when we think of
animals that we eat,
we have very distinct classifications.
You tell people you eat bear.
They go,
Oh God.
And I did,
you know when the first hunts that you
tried to take me on was black bear hunt?
And I was like,
man,
I don't want to go.
It took some getting used to.
Yeah.
Now I'm like,
when we go on,
let's go get some blueberry bears.
Yeah,
I have.
I,
you know,
I have the same.
I had the same problem.
Why do I do create a hierarchy?
But I also try to like question where
the hierarchy has come from.
It comes from.
And to suss out contradiction,
but the only problem to me where it gets
problematic for me is the way that in
which it seems that you can get some
American,
so excited about
preventing any kind of exploitation of a
handful of species,
yet there,
yet they remain completely uninvolved
with the,
with the the issues and politics and
recovery efforts of other things that
needed really that need it right now.
Yeah.
You know the fact that with wolves and
grid like certain populations of grizzly
bears,
certain populations of wolves have
reached recovery objective.
Yet we still cover them on the
endangered species act because people
are wanting to use the endangered
species act to save things from any
threat of exploitation at all,
like nothing to do with what?
Nothing to do with what the legislation
was meant for.
It's become.
It's become the favorite animal act,
and if you want to initiate something
called the favor animal act and try to
get it passed by Congress,
feel free,
but don't steal the ESA and take it away
from its intended purpose.
In order to protect your stuffed animal
animal
sales,
you had a very important point on one of
your podcast where you're talking about
population numbers,
population objectives,
and you were saying that will like if
you look at a elk,
for example,
in some places elk are extremely common.
You know,
in Colorado for instance,
there's more elk in Colorado that I
think any other state,
but yeah.
Bye Bye.
I think of almost like a factor too.
There's a lot.
So if you tell people in Colorado that
elk are in danger,
they're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Go to Florida.
There's no elk and elk are gone.
Wolves,
same thing,
right?
Elk are gone from 90 percent of their
historic range in the US.
Wow.
Ninety percent.
Yet no one has a problem with elk
hunting seasons,
right,
exactly.
But them,
that's the thing.
Who is eating wolves?
Well,
that's the problem.
And Wolf Dog.
No,
I don't think it's an arctic explorer as
his favorite wild meat.
What's loved?
Oh,
he's a psycho dude.
You know,
he ate two carpaccio.
He ate a,
they found a.
Oh,
a desiccated
whale beached.
And it had been like in the,
in the salt and its tongue was dried out
and he cut the tongue out and he said
the how.
They boiled repeatedly,
repeatedly tried to get the salt out and
eventually ate it.
And then he ran into some eskimo hunters
who said that thing been laying there
for three years.
Jesus Christ.
What?
He was hardcore.
How the fuck did he eat in three year
old tongue.
Like you said,
you just kept boiling it and rebounded.
Do it hit anyone.
Like if you want to do,
he can't have that some bitch on your
podcast.
He made Stevinson.
He's got a book my life with the Eskimo.
So he made first contact with a lot of
people in the High Arctic.
They knew he was meeting people who knew
about whites but hadn't met and yet.
Wow.
And what was funny about this dude is
how frustrated he would get with a
trying to show him his shit,
which he thought they'd be blown away
by.
So He'd let get out a gun or one day,
he's one days.
Explain to people that we can do.
He's like,
my people,
you know,
we can do surgery.
What year was this?
He was making first contact and the
early 19 hundreds of Blake,
like coronation goal Victoria island up
open the Canadian High Arctic again.
They knew,
they knew that there was whites.
They hadn't met any whites yet and he'd
come to them and um,
he'd expect blown way.
Like he,
he shows some guys his firearm has gone
and this dude's like,
yeah,
that's cool.
But I know a guy that can shoot his bow
and his error will travel to the far
side of the mountain and kill a care
with the,
you can't even see.
Or he was saying we can do surgery on
people do an appendectomy.
And he says,
I know a guy that can take your whole
spine and skull and brain out and put it
back in again.
He was talking about telescopes and he's
like,
you can see the moon craters.
And they're like,
I know guys been to the moon
in haunted there.
So that's one upmanship dude.
It's like,
it's the greatest book man.
How frustrated he gets from one of the
cool things he describes as a,
he describes how they would kill,
you know,
when they killed a polar bear,
they would bring the head back and put
in their lodge,
sort of like,
I don't want to draw it,
like I don't want to push this too far,
but much in the same way you might bring
a head home and hanging on your wall.
They would bring it home and put in
their lodge and the thinking has
explained to staff and some was that um,
I'm bringing him home so that he can
observe me and my family
and see that we're good people.
And when he goes to the afterlife he
will tell other bears if you got to get
killed by somebody,
not a bad guy to have it happen.
That guys.
Okay.
And I often point out about the,
the animal skulls and hides in my own
home that I feel like,
you know,
I don't want to make myself seem to
spirits will in some ways I,
I think of that.
I think of that with the animals.
I haven't in my.
Just a concept that you run in your
mind,
eh,
that I run in my mind.
I think about him.
Why was I talking about step?
Oh,
loved wolf.
So he ate every damn thing like Muskox,
Caribou,
walrus.
He ate everything.
And in talks repeatedly about his
preference for wolf meet preference.
Above all,
I'm telling you,
you read my life with the Eskimo.
Well,
you ate a coyote.
Yeah.
What was that like?
Didn't like it.
But here's the problem that I've run
into because I in,
in Vietnam,
I a fair bit of domestic dog.
I Caio and I know monkey red howler
monkey.
Those are my big,
my big transgressions of me.
You know,
we all,
like I said,
I admitted earlier to having my own
animal hierarchies and those were the
times when I've sort of strayed
uncomfortable ground for myself.
I'm canines and hominids or they hominid
no,
not a harm in primate primate.
So,
um,
yeah,
I,
I get like a,
a,
I get where I can't really tell what it
tastes like.
It's difficult to tell what it actually
taste like because you're feeling that
there's so many other things going on,
emotions,
thoughts,
contributions and and I get like a hot,
a hot guilty feeling,
Woo.
But when I was in Vietnam,
they described dog as a hot food and I
kept asking him what that meant because
I didn't really understand but it does
it like makes me sweaty.
I thought it was like a guilt thing,
but people would,
they would eat it and serve it around
the holidays.
So the lunar new year,
it was auspicious.
Suspicious.
It's auspicious to eat dog meat in the
days leading up to the lunar new year
and it's a game.
It's a food that you have.
It's like a risky enterprise and summer.
Vietnam is kind of a risky enterprise to
eat deer and it'd be like a dog.
Yeah.
I'm sorry to eat dog.
And it's like some of the people like
these restaurants open up that are only
open that time of year and there's
people coming in to like bring in good
luck,
risky enterprise.
How so a guy told me that.
One of the guys I interviewed told me
that he was unable to get his,
he's unable to have children and they
determined that it was.
It was on him.
His wife was fertile,
he was infertile.
He ate dog
and it changed.
His fortunes have changed his luck and
he got his wife pregnant.
Now he says,
I will not eat dog again for fear that I
would undo what I did.
It's a powerful food.
This is a sentiment held more in the
north than in the held more like I spent
time in Hanoi and I spent time in Saigon
or Ho Chi Minh City as the sentiment
that was expressed,
more like in more of a semi spiritual
way in the north than it was in the
south.
Now,
a translator that I had hired a told me
I don't eat dark.
Uh,
he said,
I don't eat dogs.
I have a dark.
I went to his house to see his dog.
I come in and the dog is in a small cage
probably.
I'm not exaggerating.
I say it was,
yeah,
I mean it was probably maybe two feet by
three and a half feet
and it's a wire mesh cage and there's a,
like a drip pan below it basically to
collect the animal's waste and,
and there's a bowl of rice in the dog,
just goes ape shit and when,
when we come in and it just like looking
at the dog,
it just was not,
it just did not seem like a well dog.
Okay.
I said to him,
uh,
and he lives like a very busy in Hanoi,
like you walk out and it's just the full
Vietnam may him scooters.
It's just like insane.
And I said to him,
so you just take them out,
like you can just go walk them
here.
And he kind of looks at me like he
doesn't understand when talking about.
And it turns out that that dog hadn't
been out of that cage since he brought
it home.
That was his pet dog,
which he kept like a parakeet Jesus
Christ.
He said I wouldn't eat.
Now conversely,
in the training,
I went out to a farm.
There were a guy has a small plot of
land,
he's there,
they have like a,
basically there's was system there,
the you have very poor farmers who don't
own the land,
but it's state owned land,
government own land,
but they have subsistence farms and this
guy raised a sugar cane.
He had an air gun,
you can't have a regular gun,
but he had an air gun and he would hunt
various,
uh,
arboreal marsupial's and,
and things to eat and he had some water
river flowing through his place and he
had a small amount of livestock and
raise some crops and peppers and various
things and he had a bunch of dogs
running around on his place,
just pet dogs.
He was explaining to me that now and
then when the dogs are bred up to a
number that's hard to support them,
the dog buyer comes and the dog buyer
will give you some cash for your excess
dog population.
And those are the dogs that go into the
markets of Vietnam.
Other countries actually have places
where they're like breeding and rearing
dogs for slaughter.
But that was the Vietnamese system.
So it might've been,
I have many interesting things about
this whole thing is about being like
comparing like this guy's pet to this
guy's livestock.
You sort of got into this thing as which
is the more enviable position,
which is more enviable position
livestock.
I'll take that life over.
Then living in the cage,
shitting onto like a great.
And I went to visit a guy that actually
a wholesaler who buys the dogs from
farmers on the countryside and he comes
back and they fatten.
They would fatten the dogs on beef,
stomach beef trim.
Basically the stuff that in the US we
send a rendering plants.
Like,
like when,
when when they slaughter cat,
almost everything,
you know,
once the meats gone,
everything goes to a rendering plant.
He would buy basically what us
production facility send to a rendering
plant and that's what he would fatten
dog on.
And you'd go to the markets and they'd
have dogs stack like just dog part
stacked up pyramids at the market.
It was bizarre to see man,
and I'll tell you I'm a,
I went out in different places and with
different people and different things.
I went out for seven nights in a row and
I could never get beyond.
I could never get beyond my own biases
about what's food and what's not food.
It was just like very difficult for me
to,
to eat it and fake my way through and it
was hard.
So I do understand when people come to
me and they're looking,
they're like,
hey man,
a bear,
like in,
uh,
you know,
I'm 100.
I've,
I've 100 grade I've hunted and eaten
hundreds and hundreds of pounds of black
bear meat.
Um,
when people come in,
they're like,
dude,
I just like,
I don't want to act like that.
They're coming.
When people come to me and express
disapproval,
right?
I don't want to act like I can't
understand where they're coming from
because I had the same thing I felt
there.
Right.
I've ever making the argument.
I never fact checked it,
but I feel it is.
There are more people in this world who
live in a country where it's socially
acceptable to eat dog meat.
The not.
I haven't formally fact check that,
but I remember looking at some basic
figures and thinking that that was true.
Well,
it's interesting that we choose to not
eat pigs,
but pigs are probably as intelligent if
not more to choose to eat pigs rather.
Yeah.
Probably as intelligent or more than
dogs.
Yeah,
and dogs are probably more dangerous
when they're feral than pigs are.
Yeah.
When pigs are feral,
they generally avoid people.
When dogs are feral,
they known always.
I mean there was an instance a couple
years ago outside of Atlanta were an
elderly couple was attacked and someone
was killed by wild dogs.
Yeah.
The Australian Dingo traces back to
being a is a,
is a dog who knows it's ancestry to,
to human activities.
So that's it really.
So it used to be a domesticated animal.
It was,
yeah.
It was a very early form.
Wow.
Check that out.
Make sure I'm right about that.
What the,
what the genetic history that Dingo is.
What's their wild dog called?
Dingo.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think it's some kind of a.
it's like a dog breed.
Probably Find Adam Green tree holding
one up by his ankles to the fucking
bowl
arrow hole.
And it's a wild dog.
Says wild but lupus.
But what's,
uh,
what's his ancestry?
Just uh,
just google dingoes were once domestic
dogs.
Dingo domesticated animal.
I'm looking at the genetic status origin
here.
I'll just pull it up so you can see
Indian wolf and Arabian Wolf evolved
from.
Hmm.
Here.
Mad.
Don't feel like I'm wrong.
Hm.
Interesting.
Widely held.
The dingoes have evolved from the Indian
Wolf.
Yeah,
right there.
6,000,
10,000 years ago.
Bread from a was assumed for all
domestic dogs.
The theory was based on the
morphological similarities of the Dingo
skulls and the skulls of the subspecies
of wolves.
Genetic analysis indicated that a much
earlier domestication.
Huh?
Oh.
So there is a domestication.
New study suggests dingoes may have in
the south China.
Okay.
So you have humans.
Interesting.
So they were originally domesticated and
then cut loose.
Yeah,
we,
I mean,
I,
I've told you,
I mean I have my own.
I had my own thing about bear and then I
hunted bear and eight bear.
And then that thing went away.
Yeah.
It's just been this what it is,
but it still doesn't seem the same to me
as like a deer.
Like if you,
if you gave me a choice,
hey,
would you rather go hon?
Axis deer,
which I've never hunted seems so much
more natural to me.
Think go hunt black bear.
Yeah.
I know.
I have such a complicated,
a complicated sets of feelings about
black bears.
And as a hunter strange,
I've gotten to the thing where I'm
maybe before I even say I'm going to say
why it's not quite strange.
I have found that a lot of big game
hunters
will
do some amount of bear hunting,
get a couple of bears and then drift
away from bear hunting.
Um,
they still respect how difficult it is
and how much you can learn about
barriers by fine at blop you have gotten
some bears are always excited to go on a
bear hunt if it's someone's first
bear hunt,
like to like,
you know,
I have no desire if you want to go,
I would love to go along.
But it's something to happen.
But whereas like something like elk,
the more you get and the more you eat,
the more you want to get in,
the more you want to eat.
Right.
But you don't,
you think that's a public pressure thing
though in a lot of ways about bears
because I,
I've described even to my friends about
hunting bear and that just put their
head back like they're fine with me
hunting deer.
They're fine with me.
Hunting pigs.
Everybody seems to be in supportive
hunting pigs.
Yeah.
You know how my brother,
you know,
my brother put the bear thing is.
Here's the conundrum for him and it's
pretty simple.
I'm a bear.
Has a very beautiful,
very usable hide.
Okay.
So you know like deer hides.
You can,
you can throw it through a process,
you can get like a buck skin from it.
You can get some deer hides,
you can get a pretty good usable leather
that,
that the use used to make apparel.
In fact,
everybody knows Daniel Boone,
right?
Daniel Boone was a much of his life was
spent in the business of trading deer
hides.
Daniel Boone was a commercial hunter.
He will go out and shoot white tail deer
in the summer when their hides were thin
and sell them,
and it was used for industrial work
where it was used for work apparel.
Like basically the 17 fifties version of
carhartt close was made out of deer hide
summer.
Dear.
I'm not familiar with that term.
Carhartt.
What does that mean?
Like carhartt work wear?
Carhartt jackets,
Carhartt Pants,
Jesus Christ.
Joe.
No,
I know.
Dickies.
Yeah,
same thing.
Okay.
I never heard a carhartt.
This same thing with Jamie.
Like you know,
like work pants.
He got like a little holster for a
hammer and shut up inside of them.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm so used to make them out of
Buckskin.
Yeah.
Like work,
work apparel and his time was making
bucks again.
Those things smelled great.
At the end of the day I'll do.
My Dad had my dad saved a lot of his
deer and had a uh,
an had a sport coat made out of his own
deer and do that thing was amazing and
smelled good.
Really?
I'll do as a nicest jacket.
He's dead.
I should find.
I should go dig around and stuff and
find that he,
it was dyed black is beautiful coat,
but it hadn't had one mate.
You've shot a lot of deer.
Well that wasn't good at is.
Uh,
it's like,
yes you can do stuff with,
but it's not really in today's age of
other fabrics is not practical.
However,
a bear hide has timeless beauty and
timeless application.
Have you ever thought about making a
jacket at a bear hide?
Yes.
Did you ever do it?
Yeah.
Well no,
because what I was doing for a long time
was saving up my bear hides and I wanted
to cut them into like nine or 10 inch
squares and have a very large conflict
are made out of many different bears cut
into squares stitched.
I haven't given up on that idea,
but I give a lot of my bear hides away
to people who really liked them anyway.
When you get a bear,
it's like no one in their right mind
gets rid of a bear hide.
Right?
So you get one and you get a Tan and
then you've got to bear hide.
And once you got to bear hide and it's
like on the floor and then you got bear
hide over the back of the couch and you
got to bear hide hanging on the wall,
you get to a point where,
um,
you don't need any more bear hides,
you eat the meat and you have the
highest but you don't need more bear
hides and when you get a bear there's an
expense to getting the high prepared but
you feel wasteful not using the height.
So it was very hard to shoot a bear just
for me.
Right,
because you feel like you're wasting
something that people really want and
it's beautiful.
And people like to use the,
decorate their homes and use it as a
totem of the wild as opposed to a white
tail deer with very few people do
anything with the highest.
Yeah.
So now,
like one day Danny was like the last
bear he got,
he got up to the bear and,
and,
and found himself just kinda.
He goes,
I just don't,
I don't need,
you know,
like I look at it and I'm like,
I have like a set of obligations that
this animal now and uh,
I'm not excited about it anymore.
I don't want another bear hide.
It's,
it's an expense.
Then he just,
he never killed another bear.
Wow.
He's got some bear hides and he loves,
but he just,
he just got to where he's got enough
other stuff to eat.
He's a moose snob.
He killed a moose every year.
Likes the moose meat,
um,
feeds his family,
moves,
feeds his family salmon primarily.
Well,
if he kills a moose every year.
The other problem with that is you're
talking about like 600 pounds of meat,
right?
Yeah.
He's got a family of four.
He Burns through it plus let me,
I'll eat.
Yeah.
So,
but that's just kinda like where he got
in.
I knew a lot of people,
for whatever reason,
I used to hunt bears and my other
brother and then he don't.
He,
he like when he's out at his,
his,
when he's out at his wife's ranch,
he'll see bears running around during
bear sees and he doesn't even think
about going hunting for him and he used
to hunt bears.
What happens?
And you just quit.
You just quit wanting to hunt bears.
One of my favorite episodes of yours was
on the Prince of Wales Island where you
had a bear in your site and just
decided,
I don't want to shoot this bear.
Yeah.
It's just like I,
I really,
I enjoy watching them.
I enjoy hunting.
I enjoy making smoke.
Black Bear Hams out,
but it's like,
uh,
I,
would you ever do that with any other
animal though?
Do what?
Look at it and say,
I don't want to shoot this.
Like if you saw mature,
a mature mule deer,
180 inch mule deer.
No,
no.
Right,
right.
But I could picture like with,
with,
you know it,
there's a handful of animals that
you know what it is you can't.
One of is,
one of the things is this,
I can't help but watch a bear if I'm out
and I glass up a bear,
you know,
when I say out glass up,
I mean like if I'm sitting on a big
glass and tin or glass and knob up some
highway,
have a commanding view of the lands
glassing meaning use your binoculars to
look at the landscape the way that the
way I generally hunt.
I hunt a lot of open country in the
American west and then Alaska and things
where you have good visibility.
Um,
the bulk of the time I spent hunting,
I spend on a good lookout point,
a high point where you can see,
you know,
a good one,
hundred 80 degree view or maybe not
always 108,
sometimes three 60,
whatever,
a commanding view of the surrounding
landscape.
And we generally hunt by sitting there
and observing a with binoculars and just
watching,
watching to the point where sometimes
we'll spend days doing nothing but
watching animals through binoculars.
And um,
and when you get good at this,
you,
you find animals that people would never
in a million years find that other
people would never in a million years
locate when I'm doing that and I find a
bear and I'm observing a bear,
you,
I would never leave that bear
to go do some other thing.
When you find a bear,
like when I find a bear,
I watch him until he's gone.
You can't turn away from them because I
always feel like at any point he's going
to do some amazing thing that would blow
your mind.
Like,
what?
I don't like crush something skull.
I don't know.
They're just,
they like are always doing weird things.
They eat a vast array of things.
My friend John Dudley was watching a
bear through his binoculars and he saw a
bear run up on a Moose and smash it on
the back and crush it.
That's what I talking.
He saw grizzly smash a on the back and
break its back,
literally hit it so hard that it snapped
the Moose is back and then he tackled it
once it was down,
started eating.
I haven't seen that,
but that's what I'm looking for.
So you watch them and there's this sort
of anticipation was seeing them right.
Deer,
they're very interesting and the more
you wash them,
the more you learn about them.
And the thing that I've always been
fascinated by and was talking about with
some friends of mine recently was,
um,
how interested I become an interpersonal
relationship is among mule deer,
like the body language they use and how
you can locate deer that you can't see
just based on body language of deer that
you can see that you watch them and you
become aware of things that are aware of
and you learn where other things are
that are out of your view.
Just by how,
just by what it's doing,
both male and female.
Generally it's,
it's doe,
not sometimes in a general,
the most obvious one is dosed that no,
there's a buck around.
You took me for body language there and
then doles that are encountering another
band of Doe's have a body language they
use and you just get used to this and
you sort of a base.
Yeah,
and then once you see it you go like,
oh,
he knows about it.
There's a deer somewhere that's not net
group and that deer is aware of the fact
that the deer is not in the group and
it's like wondering about it and you
just see that.
So I'm interested that kind of stuff.
But I could walk away from deere.
You,
I could see there's some deer and I can
just go look in another direction.
Something about me makes me stare at
bears.
Wow.
I can't give up on them.
Like I just like I'm watching them,
watching them,
watching them.
Do you have the same feeling about
wolverines?
Does the first bull run over?
See my whole life.
That was the one that was the thing on
my checklist.
Like as far as like if you large land
mammals.
That was the one I was missing.
So you'd never seen one?
I mean,
yeah,
large like American land,
mammals.
I.
That was me.
That was the one missing from my list.
Do you think you'd feel a feeling of
remorse if you shot the one that you.
The only one you saw.
That's why I said I wasn't going to
touch that screen because of that.
Yeah.
I even said right then in there I said
I'm not going to shoot the first one is
something I saw.
That's how I feel like when I was saying
earlier about the black hole of Africa,
I always imagined that guy's going to
Africa and being like,
no shit.
That's what one of those shoes look
like.
Well that's right.
It is.
Yes.
I just didn't,
I hadn't built up a context about it.
So then we're like talking about.
So if you see another one,
yeah,
I'd,
I'd reconsider.
But no,
I didn't want to shoot the first
wolverine I ever laid eyes on.
That's what I was trying to get.
You know,
Yannis has seen,
um,
you know,
he's been out Caribou hunting and watch
wolverine scavenge and Caribou
Carcasses.
And so I was like,
you know,
he's not the first one you saw and then
we just dilly dallied no one so he could
have shot it because it wasn't the first
one he saw,
but no one was feeling any.
It was just one of those things.
No one was feeling,
I felt,
you know,
great.
Assuming I remember watching my youtube,
by the way,
a white tail deer looks you.
I remember watching the
first links I ever saw and um,
I feel that,
uh,
um,
anthropomorphizing a fair bit here,
but he was the first links that I ever
saw and I just had a strong feeling that
I was the first person he ever saw
a look of.
I'm
a look of like sheer,
like uncomprehensive for what he was
seeing.
Wow.
And he's like,
he's like,
is this good,
bad?
What does this mean?
And you see what kind of run through all
these calculations in his mind and just
drift off.
Like after awhile I,
he's like,
Eh,
something about it.
This thing has got its eyes,
him looking at me like his eyes are
centered on his face,
right?
Like a Predator maybe for someone tells
me something,
you know,
he's looking at me very intently.
He's not trying to act like I'm not
there and therefore he can't see me,
you know,
and you just see them kind of run it
through his head and just be like,
yeah,
no,
because nothing good's going to come
out.
I didn't go off the road direction,
but just based on where I was.
Yeah.
I mean it was very safe to say he'd
never run into a person and I'd never
run into a length.
We just had this moment of um,
you know,
I,
I carry a,
an,
a,
a cultural awareness.
So I at least knew about what I was
looking at but,
but he was in this point of I'm just,
you know,
processing and like the white tail that
you encountered who damn sure knew what
that,
that thing carries with it.
Yeah.
We talked about it before the podcast
started,
but,
uh,
I was hunting with my friend John Dudley
and we were in the tree stand and we
were supposed to get down at 1:30 and at
1:25.
I'm like,
what do you want you want to call it and
then eat lunch.
He's like,
yeah,
so I climbed down first and that 1:25
like five fucking minutes before we set
it and this big mature whitetail walks
through and John Signals to me does the
bowl winkle thing,
but putting his thumbs on his head and
he starts pointing and then I realized
as a deer coming down the path and so I
kind of hide behind the tree,
but there was all these branches in
front of me.
Anyway,
you've already heard the story,
but for the people listening,
that deer locked eyes with me and there
was this intensity,
like immediate intensity in his eyes
that had never experienced an animal
looking at me like it was.
It was very tuned in.
He knew exactly that I shouldn't be
there and I just froze.
I was wearing Camo.
He's looking me right in the face,
like right in.
His eyes were bulging out of his head.
I turned around and bolted,
but it's like electricity to them like
they know I have very vivid memories of
when I was 12 and had just hit legal
hunting age and Michigan and I was
sitting on the ground hunting squirrels
on a farm owned by a man named,
uh,
there a lot and
leaning against a tree and,
and having,
uh,
for corn white tail coming through the
woods and you know,
like this,
like a buck like that.
This isn't always true,
but Gianluca for chrome white tells a
year and a half old the way,
even at that time,
you start hunt squirrels,
September 15 and Michigan.
So,
I mean,
that deere was,
you know,
he could have been as little as 15,
16 months old.
He locked on to me,
saw me and knew to look in my eyes but
didn't know what the Hell I was.
I remember him coming at me and coming
at me and coming at me and getting so
scared and I and I had always known
like,
you just like there's a thing you just
you don't yell in the woods like you
don't make noise in the woods.
You'd try to be quiet.
And it was.
I remember grabbing sticks and trying to
snap them to make a noise to make that
deer spook off,
you know,
but being like conflicted between just
being scared shitless and doing the
thing you don't do like as a hunter is
you just learn like don't make loud
noises in the woods when people made
loud noises.
Okay.
It makes me cringe,
man.
Well,
what's interesting about this mature
deer that saw me and freaked out when he
saw me is that literally a minute before
that,
because I was down when I was down,
that deer came through with two other
deer and one of 'em look to be like
maybe a two year old deer.
And one of them was baby.
One of them was like one year old and
the one year old got within 15 feet of
me.
Yeah.
I just pinned up against the tree and
the one year old walked right by me,
had no idea it was alive.
The other one that was younger deer
walked by me,
didn't look my direction at all.
The old one looked right at me.
He's like,
fuck this.
He knew right away he'd seen people
before maybe.
I mean they're in Iowa and I was really
different because I always a great state
for bow hunting because they have a very
short gun season.
It's only shotgun.
So.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You don't get a big rifle heart.
Right.
So a lot of what they're dealing with is
a bowhunters.
So He.
I mean,
he might've known that I had a bow.
who the fuck knows?
Saw a bow and say,
I've seen that fucking thing before.
Somebody shot me in the ass with one of
those a year ago.
That's one of the things I like that egg
about big bucks.
I,
you know,
I think that culturally in this country
we're kind of getting where it's almost
like this thick accepted idea that
you're supposed to hate trophy hunters.
Right.
But um,
I eat everything I kill and I will even
talk about there's like meat box and
shooter box,
right?
And meaning like there's like big huge
box that are cool and meat box they eat,
but I always eat my shooter box.
It's like,
you know,
like shoot,
a big buck is elite one.
It's illegal.
Two,
I love them.
You can Pepsi challenge them.
I can.
Pepsi challenge of five-year-old deer
and in a two year old deer and you
can't.
Well you can because you're really good
at cooking.
Yeah.
But I'm saying it's good.
If you know how to cut it and trim it
and stuff,
they're great.
Right?
Yeah.
So point being I do like to look for big
animals.
Okay.
I like,
like if you,
if I have to deer and I can go after a
small one or go after one,
I like to go after the big one.
One of the things I like about going
after the big one and the challenge of
it is that they are harder to get and
the reason they're harder to get it
because they have learned from mistakes,
you know,
a big buck to,
uh,
to,
experienced hunter when he sees a big
buck.
He sees more than the antlers,
the antlers one up kind of becoming like
symbolic of something of a very worthy,
challenging cory because he hasn't made
any mistakes yet,
right?
You can have big box in areas that have
very low predation and low hunter
pressure and he could get big and still
make some mistakes because he doesn't
have as many mistakes that could be
made.
But a really big buck and an area that
has a lot of lines,
a lot of coyotes,
wolves,
human hunters.
Um,
he's big because he doesn't,
he hasn't messed up,
he hasn't fucked up,
doesn't fuck up.
He remembers stuff,
you know,
we had a occasion to watch.
We're hunting in Colorado hunt mule deer
this year.
And we watched,
um,
I glanced up at pretty nice buck and
they went up and do an aspen grove.
He was traveling with a bunch of dose
and they all go into an aspen grove
later.
Yannis was looking above there and he
said,
there's some coyotes rolling down into
that aspen grove where all the deer,
when it's now the middle of the day and
it's rifle season,
has been rifle season on and off through
a couple of weeks of hunting season,
the coyotes go into the Aspen Grove.
All those deer component out of that
Aspen Grove.
I at the time comment on how it seemed
like someone like squeezing a tube of
toothpaste,
the way the deer came shooting out of
that Aspen Grove and ran out across a
large sage flat exposing themselves.
The one deer out of the group that
didn't walk out of that stage,
that didn't walk out of that Aspen Grove
was the big buck.
Never budged because he ran a
calculation in his head where he's like,
I get it.
Y'all scared of those coyotes.
I'm afraid of the unknown.
I would rather stay in here and my
little thicket and he stood up,
we could see him stand up in there,
that son of a bitch would not move and
that's during the Rut.
So every thing in his body is saying
chase those donors and breed those dogs.
That's all he's thinking about.
His breeding dose.
A dumb Bach would have chased those.
Those if not for fear of the coyote,
he would've chased the dose just because
for fear of that,
another buck is going to go breed them.
But he resisted that.
Right?
He resisted the fear of the coyotes,
but he's like,
I know that there is trouble when you
run out in the open
shit shoots at you or whatever.
He knew.
Wow.
He just sweated it out,
you know?
Wow.
So it's like he didn't like and he
lived.
He didn't mess up.
Well,
a big book like that is also kind of
threatening to a coyote to.
I'm sure.
I'm sure that's part of it.
Yeah,
sure.
As part of it,
but it's just like he,
there's a threat in instinctively or
whatever because here's the thing that
they weren't,
they were not interested in those deer.
They weren't chasing him.
I think they know because they see they
lose Fonz to them all the time.
Right.
I mean they see stuff die from,
but it's like,
you know,
right now there's a couple of.
Kyle's is at that time of year isn't
going to drag down a healthy fire.
Mueller,
they weren't even chasing him,
but he just like,
he knew,
you know.
Um,
and that's one of the things I admire
about like the old ones,
if you can consider,
if you can go into areas that have heavy
hunting pressure and consistently find
those deer,
it's,
you know,
it's like,
it's the highest challenge.
Yeah,
man,
I respect it.
Well,
it's a very difficult quarry and when
you're eating that animal,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's a completely different sense of
not just accomplishment but connection
to that animal.
Then buying some stake in a store or
shooting some button buck.
Oh yeah.
It's such a.
that's the thing that winds up being
like such an obvious conversation that
it's that you sometimes feel like it's.
I'm done having that conversation with
people who don't get is like shooting
fish in a barrel.
Right?
It's like so obvious and so easy that
you almost feel like a little bit like,
like almost unfair to bring it up.
Will you say that like,
yeah.
Why do something like pro for the same
reason why you challenged to chase after
big bucks?
Like you're telling me that somehow you
like if you eat meat,
that somehow the system by which you go
about getting meat to farms and stores
and Shit like that is somehow morally or
aesthetically or or ethically are
somehow superior to me eating an animal
that I've hunted myself from a
sustainable population as well managed
and that I've decorated my home with
it's parts that will be there until I
die and then we'll decorate the homes of
my children.
If you're telling me somehow that I'm
like depraved
for that,
I have a hard time engaging in the
conversation because I can't.
I just don't understand it well with
other mediators years.
It's a ridiculous conversation.
It's very short sided conversation and
it's part of the problem is that people
have so many things going on in their
lives there.
If you have a job and you have a family
and you have some sort of hobby,
you've eliminated 90 percent of your
time.
How much time do you have to actually
immerse yourself in wildlife and
understand the politics of it,
understand what's really going on out
there in the world.
How many people have actually seen an
overhead view of the Pacific northwest
and looked down at all the forest and
just done the calculations in their head
about these animals and how many of them
there are and how much of the wild west
is filled with animals.
And that doesn't stop people from having
opinions of,
of course,
does it.
They're just not educated.
It's the reason why.
And,
uh,
is the reason why after all these years,
I still have no opinion on obamacare
because I do not understand it.
So I'll point out like I have no opinion
now trying to have this infectious
result on people where people will stop
talking about shit they don't fully
understand.
No.
People have these knee jerk opinions.
They're just,
they lock them in like this is as a left
wing person.
I think this is a right wing person.
I think that,
I think as we pointed out,
you and I both,
I believe that that's a ridiculous
perspective.
Can I close a bit of flattery please?
Um,
it didn't occur to me til I was coming
down here today,
but I've been railing a lot on,
uh,
the,
the echo chamber that we all live in.
Um,
and I think if anyone goes and you look
at your,
you look at your facebook feed or any
number of things like we surround
ourselves with people who tell us what
we think,
you know,
and it's kind of become very obvious and
I think that this presidential election
cycle really brought it out where you
had just two vastly different narratives
playing out and people on each side of
it feeling like so absolutely certain
that not only were they right,
but everyone felt the way they felt.
Okay.
Right.
And it's just been a big part of the
national conversation.
Like the echo chamber thing.
Um,
what I have found with people that
listen to your show who come up to me
and be like,
oh,
I heard you on Joe show.
The Times I've been on there is that you
haven't,
you've somehow managed to defy that
where you have the,
the right wing nut jobs and the left
wing nut jobs all listening to at the
same time
in the middle of the rotors.
But like when someone calls up and says,
I was listening to Joe Rogan podcast,
I'm always thinking like,
like,
what does that make you?
It doesn't mean anything.
It's like,
I don't know,
just the fact that you listened to it.
I don't know what.
That doesn't tell me anything about you.
Other than that you'd like to wrestle
with ideas because this is one of the
few places where people are talking
about shit and you talk about stuff and
bring it up where it's like people are
willing because of you in the way you're
handling it.
They're willing to subject themselves to
disparate views for a minute.
And I don't know what it is,
the formula if you've even thought about
it,
but it's a nice invention.
Uh,
it's just how I look at things.
I think I don't,
uh,
you know,
I have my rigid lines that I won't
cross,
you know,
where I think something is evil or
something is ethically wrong.
But I'm willing to entertain ideas and
I'm not,
I'm not rigid.
Like if if someone comes to me and they
tell me that I'm wrong about something,
I'll go really like,
how am I,
how am I wrong?
If they tell me I'm wrong,
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm fucking wrong.
I didn't know it was wrong.
Like I'm not married to my ideas and I
that's,
that's a real problem that people have
where they define themselves by their
knowledge they,
they think they're smart or they're.
They think they're valuable because they
have a certain amount of information in
their head and I think that's crazy
because there's,
especially as you start getting into
more things or get exploring new
subjects and new topics,
you realize it is impossible to know
everything.
It's not possible.
So for you to define yourself by the
knowledge that you know or the knowledge
you don't know,
it seems kind of crazy.
I think you're far better off defining
yourself,
not even defining yourself,
but far better off approaching the world
by searching for the truth,
you know,
and not being connected or married to
any ideas.
It's far too often people get into these
discussions with people and it becomes a
game of trying to win,
you know,
trying to one up the person with
information or data and then coming
along,
coming off of that with the victory.
Yeah,
no,
I'm with you.
Yeah,
I mean that's what you're seeing on all
these news shows,
man.
You seen.
One of the things that I did during the
election was while the debates were
going on in and post debate,
I would bounce back and forth and spend
an hour on Fox News and an hour on cnn
and I was like,
what is the world like?
This is so baffling because these are,
these are just enforced narratives from
one side and the other.
And I think the,
the,
the country suffers because of that.
People suffer because of that.
It's a tribal inclination that I think
we have to,
uh,
to support one side or the other or to
adopt these predetermined patterns of
behavior are predetermined belief
systems or the or that it's shameful to
switch positions.
Yeah.
That it's a flip flopper like how the
fuck do you not learn?
I mean he,
he,
you can't be right all the time and you
can have preconceived notions that
turned out to be incorrect and you have
to be able to recognize those.
Yeah,
it's good.
I enjoy like I enjoy talking to you.
Oh,
thank you.
It's always fun.
Bad.
We should definitely do this more often.
But I think um,
yeah,
I mean I,
I appreciate that perspective that you
have to,
that you are willing to say it was like
I don't have an opinion on obamacare
because I really don't know know enough
about it.
That's,
that's really healthy and really
important and for some reason really
rare,
especially with a well read person like
yourself.
It makes you sound a little bit like a
dumb ass.
I sound like a dumb ass all the time,
but I'm willing to say it,
you know,
I would be remiss if we ended this
podcast without discussing the revenant
because you fucking crushed me on that.
I love that movie.
I thought it was bad ass and I found out
it was all bullshit.
I,
I only have a couple minutes.
I got a,
I got to leave,
but I'll,
uh,
explain everything that was bullshit
about the revenue first I want to say,
um,
my,
my dear friend and colleague,
Mo Fallon loves the revenue.
I love Mo.
He was out of town.
I,
He was,
he was hoping to come by and say hi.
But he's,
he's in a,
he's in.
Where is he?
He's in the middle east somewhere.
No,
he's in Oman right now in Jordan.
So he,
uh,
he loves it because it's cinematography
and that's the end of the conversation
for him,
but he's a cinematographer right now as
a student of american history and
someone who,
who's favorite era is the mountain man
era,
which,
which ran away to define the mountain
man and rob.
It began kind of like the moment lewis
and clark made it back to st louis after
their expedition and a man named john
colter turned around and went back out
west to trap beaver.
The mountain man era began.
One could argue that day and it ended
when the last rendezvous was held for
the free trappers,
which is an 18 forties,
very short period of time.
That's my favorite time period of
american history is the mountain man era
and it was um,
the,
the great escapades and discoveries and
adventure to the mountain men played out
in the arid west,
uh,
in the willow lined riparian zones of
the american great plains and into
Montana and valleys
by taking the most famous story from the
mountain man era,
which was the mauling by bare of,
um,
how was his name not cold,
was his name,
glass glass.
By taking that story and setting it in
the nbc along the edges of the boreal
forest and a sop and dripping landscape
of conifers,
uh,
was a,
was just a distortion of,
of every.
It'd be like if you were making a movie
about the people who came when,
when Washington and franklin and
everyone came together to drop the
american constitution and you set it
like in the jungles of Thailand.
Okay.
It's like instead of philadelphia,
it just struck me to the core.
Everything.
Hugh glass did not have a child.
You didn't have a son who he was
avenging.
Hugo asked,
got mauled by a bear and they left him
in the protection of jim bridger,
a very young jim bridger was a teenager
and another guy and hugh glass through
much struggled,
crawled his way back to I'm a fort and
he later confronted bridger
and said,
just so you know,
a body,
next time someone leaves you to watch a
guy died in the woods,
don't leave them laying around by
himself,
and that was all he did.
That's it.
It's a story of forgiveness.
Whoa.
Now in the movie,
he does forgive Bridger who cowers,
but then he has to go after the guy that
killed the son.
He didn't have.
And it's like,
if you love the story as it exists,
to me it's like the bible.
It'd be like if you were going to go
film a movie about the bible,
but change real big parts of it.
He added aliens.
Yeah.
Or like it was how people,
when
it was help is probably how people felt
when last temptation of christ came out
and they had,
you know,
the christ figure lusting for,
can't remember,
you know,
people were like,
it was an abomination.
Right.
Um,
so for me to like take parts of,
of,
of a story that demonstrates sort of the
american landscape and american grit and
turn it into a british colombian,
um,
you knoW,
uh,
a canadian farce.
It just was insulting to me.
Well,
how about the fact that he fell off a
cliff and landed on a tree.
The lot of that stuff was offsets all
fake.
None of that happened?
No.
He did a lot of crawling and I think he
ate a rattlesnake.
he did come across.
He stoled,
uh,
he came across a,
a,
a wolf kill and scavenge some parts from
and most will use doing this kroll.
Who could he walk it all?
You know,
I don't know at wHat point he started
walking.
He started out crawling.
It's a great story.
I have done damn movie like that.
I would have called it the crawling
person,
sort of like toM hanks and lost right
when he's on the island and it's a lot
of struggle,
right?
It's not likE he makes his own teletype
machine and start sending messages to
the rest of the world and I could see
how it went.
Like I've,
you know,
I've been around in business enough
where I can see that there's,
there are forces at play where they
probably went in,
they were saying,
you know what,
I get all that shit,
but you better put a love interest in
this.
Well,
isn't that a lot of ways similar to your
experiences in hollywood when you were
doing your first show?
Yeah.
You kNow,
I mean,
uh,
what was it the wild within wild within.
Yeah,
when I,
when I saw your first show and then I
spoke with you about it and you know,
they're telling me like they were trying
to like let him loose loose and then you
would shoot it.
They had like a captain.
He was just,
it was an early cOnversation I had where
I was trying to explain it.
I'm like,
no one's pretty hard,
like a lot of times stuff doesn't show
up.
And the guy who I later became friends
with and have a lot of respect for him,
but he was new to huntington,
was not,
was not new to television,
was new to hunting.
And he would say,
well,
that's why they have animal wranglers.
And that's Just one of the,
you know,
one of the early conversations we had,
I wound up liking quite a bit.
But yeah,
it was,
uh,
I think that one of the things that gets
reality television in trouble,
there's a fake anecdote I often tell
about about two kinds of producers,
right?
Like a,
it was a producer who would say to you,
how would you do that?
Whatever you're doing.
And you'd Say,
well,
I'd take this really small little knife
and I'd very carefully make a really
delicate little incision right here.
And they would say,
great film that.
And then there are ones that would go,
but could you use a machete?
And I think that,
um,
you know,
and those are two types of,
and luckily in my career I've now I'm
able to surround myself with people who,
who liked that little small knife.
Well,
you got very fortunate in that you went
to the sportsmans channel,
which gives you essentially free reign.
Yeah.
They don't mess with us.
That,
that I bought.
I just loved working with them in the
way that they've just allowed us to make
a,
just allowed us to do our own thing.
Um,
there's a lot of trust there and there's
a leap of faith there and I'd like to
think we haven't let them down.
But um,
well you are definitely onto that trust
and I think that's one of the reasons
why your shows the first show of its
kind to be on netflix.
And uh,
I think it's educating a lot of people.
It's not just a show that's a show
preaching to the choir,
you know,
it's not just a show for enthusiasts,
it's a,
it's a show that gives you an insight
and a perspective into it.
I think you're the guy to do it too,
because I think the ethics that you
carry,
you know,
like here's an important distinction,
like even though it's legal to use
walkie talkies and certain things in
some places you don't want to use them.
And I had this thought the other day
because I was listening to this podcast
and these guys were discussing different
lenses for optics.
They're comparing spotting scopes and
they started talking about walkie
talkies and they got it.
It became this combination of things
that guys love because god is love like
gadgets and tech things.
It became tech talk and and gadget talk
mixed with hunting and I,
I started thinking,
I'm like,
well,
when does this end?
Does it end with drones?
Does it not end?
Does it end with what?
I mean,
what if we come up with something
pharmacy appearing?
It's ending with drones.
Yeah,
it's ending with drones,
but it does if knowing.
Absolutely.
What's sending a drone up in the air,
it flies over.
Okay.
The herd of elk is,
you know,
a mile to the left.
We can't see him from here because
there's a ridge over us,
but we can.
We know where the wind is.
We can hook around this way and get
those animals that is in,
in your eyes,
that's cheating.
Well,
categorically at this point it's
illegal.
Is it illegal in every state,
but every state where every state,
the state were the states where it
matters because of having like open
country it is or is becoming and it's
not.
You're not going to be.
It's not gonna happen.
I mean so many states out and for I
think 13 or 14 states have banned
drones,
but it's great that they got out in
front of.
It sort of came out of nowhere,
right?
Two way.
Communications is something where a lot
of,
uh,
you know,
some states,
and I'm not talking like liberal softy
states,
man,
Montana,
Alaska,
you can't use too many communications.
The hunt because they decided that
that's where you draw the line because
they might have even discussed and the
ethics thing,
but it's something that goes back to the
great conservationist and writer,
elder leopold,
where he had said we spend a lot of
energy improving the pump but not the
well,
so we have a resource,
you know,
we have,
we have a resource of wild animals and
if you just work on improving ways to,
to pump them out without also working on
ways of improving the well and having
there be a stable population,
um,
you're gonna drain the damn well.
So when we're looking at as emerging
technologies come out wrong,
you,
you have to constantly ask yourself,
um,
with increAsed efficacy,
like if we get it where technology,
it means that every hunter is always
successful.
What will that wind up meaning for
wildlife populations,
it's not going to mean a diminishment of
wildlife populations.
It will mean a tremendous diminishment
of hunter opportunity.
You have a lot,
like a lot of over the counter public
land.
Elkanns constantly.
American west are about 10 or 20 percent
success rates.
So you give out 100 licenses,
you're going to kill about 15 out.
This is a generalization,
but generally you give them a hundred
guys an opportunity.
If you have success rates at 100
percent,
how many tags are you given out?
15,
right?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's not,
it's like you're talking about ethics,
but you're also talking about access and
privilege but aren't for you personally,
aren't you also talking about the way it
makes you feel?
Yeah,
because.
Well,
I think it makes everybody feel that
way.
Guys that shoots up behind high fence,
they don't.
Defense has never in the picture.
And guys at radio hunt,
the goddamn radios are never in the
photographs.
Right,
right.
You see a guy standing there with 10
people in the photo and you know that
nine of them were up on glass and tits
with radios
radio and the guy in,
but they sure should,
aren't wearing the headsets and the
picture.
So they kind of get to that.
They're not proud of it.
Like I would like one way to to,
to look at things for me is I'm like,
you know,
is it something that you kind of tuck
away when it's all over?
Is this something that celebrated?
Yeah.
A guy killed south with the bowl.
That's some bitch.
And beau is laying on top of the animal
always.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
The guy with the gun maybe.
Maybe not.
Who knows?
He doesn't really care.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
maybe I might put my gun in there.
It might not.
That's not the point of.
Gary would never lays out a walkie
talkie on top of the bowl.
That's very.
It takes a photograph.
That's very true.
Very true.
That's it.
Alright.
A mediator.
It's available on netflix.
30.
How many episodes?
Thirty to 32 episodes.
A meat eater on instagram.
Steven rinella on instagram and on
twitter.
Yeah,
go ahead.
You can also go to the meat eater.com
and buy all kinds of downloads of
episode.
Next time we go hunting,
we should probably bring rifles.
I love him.
Let's make something happen.
It's nolan has been itching at me.
I,
we,
we got to get together.
We've got to get together again.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate it.
Take care.
Bye everybody.
See you tomorrow with jon jones.
Hello.